It's the little things that count sometimes, like, for instance, being able to charge your phone from an extension cord that's coming out of the base of a tree. I know that sounds weird, but that's what it was.
有时候小事才最重要，比如，能用一根从树干底部引出来的延长线给手机充电。我知道这听起来很奇怪，但事实就是这样。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
These are the inventions of our people.
这些是我们人民的发明。
A teenager named Farhad showed it to me. This was at a refugee camp in Greece. New lights had just been installed nearby, and they hijacked power from that buried cable to the tree.
一个叫法尔哈德的少年给我展示了这一幕。这是在希腊的一个难民营。附近刚装了新灯，他们就从那根埋在地下的电缆里“劫持”了电源，引到了树上。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Yeah, it comes over from [INAUDIBLE], and it's coming under the ground. And the cables actually right through here.
是的，它从[无法辨认]那边过来，从地下走。电缆实际上就在这里。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
There's this one guy who's just really good with technology and electricity. And somehow he just hooked it up.
有个家伙非常擅长技术和用电。不知怎么的，他就是给连上了。
Before this, Farhad would wait sometimes for two or three hours to charge his phone at one of the chargers they have at the refugee camp. Now coming out of the ground right at the base of the tree was a cord with a socket on it, and then extension cords that allowed six phones to be charged-- incredible. Farhad breaks into English.
在这之前，法尔哈德有时得等两三个小时才能在难民营的充电站充上电。现在，从树底下的地里冒出了一根带插座的电线，还有几根延长线，可以让六部手机同时充电——太不可思议了。法尔哈德换成了英语。
I'm very happy today.
我今天很高兴。
If you heard our radio show last week, you know that we went to refugee camps all over Greece. There are 57,000 refugees in Greece, most of them escaping violence in Syria, Afghanistan, and Iraq hoping to get to Germany and other countries in Europe. But unless the politics change dramatically, they'll probably be stuck in Greece for a long time-- six months easily, maybe a lot more. The Greek government is building these camps to last for years, just in case.
如果你听了我们上周的广播节目，你就知道我们去了希腊各地的难民营。希腊目前有5.7万名难民，他们大多数是为了逃离叙利亚、阿富汗和伊拉克的暴力冲突，希望能去德国和其他欧洲国家。但除非政策发生剧烈改变，否则他们很可能会在希腊滞留很长一段时间——轻轻松松就是六个月，甚至更久。希腊政府正在建设这些营地，以备长期之需。
And the camps, people kind of know that. But mostly I think they don't like to admit it to themselves. So you see this weird mix of unrealistic hopes, and then people just starting to settle in for the long haul, moving ahead with their lives, falling in love, having babies, running little businesses, inventing projects. Today on our show we have stories of people trying to have semi-normal parts of their lives in a place that is not normal at all. From WBEZ Chicago, It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. It's our second show from Greece, from the refugee camps there. Stay with us.
难民营里的人对此心知肚明。但我认为，大多数人并不愿向自己承认这一点。所以你会看到一种奇怪的混合状态：既有不切实际的希望，同时人们也开始为长期滞留做准备，继续生活，坠入爱河，生儿育女，经营小生意，搞些发明项目。今天我们的节目里，有关于人们如何在一点都不正常的地方尝试过上半正常生活的那些故事。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。这是我们从希腊、从那里的难民营播出的第二期节目。请继续收听。
Act one, You Just Keep On Pushing My Love Over the Borderline. It's hard for single guys at the camps. Camps are mostly families. In some camps, like the one at the baseball stadium in Athens, they segregate the single men together because the families don't like them around. They view them with suspicion.
第一幕，“你不断将我的爱推向边界”。在难民营里，单身男性的日子很难过。营地里大部分是家庭。在雅典棒球场的那个营地，他们把单身男人隔离在一起，因为家庭成员不喜欢他们靠近。他们对这些人持怀疑态度。
And of course Europe sees these guys the same way. People worry they're terrorists, troublemakers. Getting permission to get out of Greece and get into some other European country might be harder for them. And just at a practical level, lots of these guys are young, have never lived without their moms washing and cooking for them. A guy named Abdul said this thing to me off mic that he was embarrassed to repeat on tape, but my interpreter, Baraa, translated. He said--
当然，欧洲也是这样看待这些人的。人们担心他们是恐怖分子，是惹麻烦的人。对他们来说，获得离开希腊进入其他欧洲国家的许可可能更加困难。而且从实际层面来看，这些年轻人很多从未离家，从未经历过没有妈妈为他们洗衣服做饭的生活。一个叫阿卜杜勒的家伙私下对我说了件事，他不好意思在录音中重复，但我的翻译巴拉翻译了出来。他说——
Basically now we're like girls. Like we'll make our bed in the morning, and then, like, we clean dishes and we clean up the entire tent.
基本上现在我们就像女孩子。我们会早上铺床，然后洗碗，打扫整个帐篷。
His tent was incredibly neat. You don't see single women traveling alone at these camps. They're almost always with their families, who are traditional and protective. But they're there, and there's flirting between men and women for sure, and sometimes more. One of our producers, Sean Cole, did meet a couple that got together as refugees at the camp in the north that was 2,000 people in tents at a highway rest stop, a gas station basically, called EKO. Here's Sean.
他的帐篷整洁得惊人。在这些难民营里，你见不到独自旅行的单身女性。她们几乎总是和家人在一起，这些家庭通常比较传统且具有保护欲。但她们确实在那里，男女之间无疑会有调情，有时甚至更多。我们的制片人肖恩·科尔在北方的一个难民营里遇到了一对情侣，那个营地有2000人挤在帐篷里，地点是在公路休息区，基本就是个加油站，叫EKO。这是肖恩。
The main thing about the couple I met, Tarek and Hadil, is the PDA. They're always moon-eyed and handholdee. And the story of how they met super delighted my translator, Manaf.
关于我遇见的那对情侣，塔里克和哈迪尔，最主要的一点就是他们当众亲热。他们总是含情脉脉、手牵着手。他们相遇的故事让我的翻译马纳夫感到特别开心。
It's like a James Bond. [INAUDIBLE] James Bond.
这就像詹姆斯·邦德。 [无法辨认] 詹姆斯·邦德。
They don't just remember the day they met, they remember the date, March 12. And it was right after they'd crossed over the water from Turkey and they were still living at the beach. Tarek was in the water going for a swim, and Hadil was up on the shore.
他们不仅记得相遇的日子，还记得具体的日期：3月12日。就在他们刚从土耳其横渡水域抵达、还住在海滩上的时候。塔里克当时正在海里游泳，哈迪尔在岸上。
He's coming out to the sea, hair wet. And she's charging her mobile phone.
他从海里出来，头发湿漉漉的。她正在给手机充电。
It's like a soap commercial.
就像肥皂剧广告一样。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
And their eyes met. Each of them would have noticed right away how deeply good looking the other is. Tarek is 25 and could play the lead in a Syrian production of Jesus Christ Superstar -- long hair, beard, hypnotic eyes. Hadil is 19 and, no joke, looks like the lady who played Mary in the movie Jesus Christ Superstar -- except when I met her, she was wearing a headscarf. It was love at first sight, for Tarek.
他们的目光交汇了。他们每个人都会立刻注意到对方有多么迷人。塔里克25岁，能在叙利亚版的《耶稣基督万世巨星》中担任主角——长发，胡须，催眠般的眼神。哈迪尔19岁，说真的，长得就像电影里演玛利亚的那位女演员——除了我见她时，她戴着头巾。对塔里克来说，这是一见钟情。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
So when I saw her, I said wow, you look beautiful. Can I speak to you?
所以当我看到她时，我说：“哇，你看起来真漂亮。能跟你说说话吗？”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
And she refused a couple of times, but I didn't give up. I kept continuing.
她拒绝了好几次，但我没有放弃。我一直在坚持。
How many times did you approach her?
你接近她多少次？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I tried for like 13, 14, or 15 times maybe--
我试了大概13、14或15次吧——
Wow.
哇。
--just you know.
——你知道的。
You're persistent.
你很执着。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Yeah, her plan was to come from Mytiline to here. My plan was to go from Mytiline to a camp called Kavala. But I changed my plans to be here with her.
是的，她的计划是从米蒂利尼到这里。我的计划是从米蒂利尼到一个叫卡瓦拉的营地。但我改变了计划，为了和她在一起。
Tarek kept pursuing Hadil even as the crowd of refugees they were in was on the move, from the island to Athens, and from Athens north by train closer to the border. He did that thing you do on the bus on a school field trip, making people switch seats so he could be next to her. She still didn't want to talk to him.
塔里克一直追着哈迪尔，哪怕他们所在的难民群体正在转移，从岛上到雅典，又从雅典坐火车北上靠近边境。他做了你在学校郊游坐大巴时会做的事，让别人换座位，好让他能坐在她旁边。她依然不想跟他说话。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
The situation is not appropriate, because obviously I'm a refugee, he's a refugee. As a refugee, I've never thought, never imagined that I would be ready to meet someone.
情况不合适，因为显然，我是难民，他也是难民。作为一名难民，我从未想过、从未想象过自己会准备好去认识某人。
I had plans of going to Germany, settle down, and then think of these hard matters. But seeing this young guy, it's like oh suddenly I fell in love with him and I want to be with him. And so I didn't care about the conditions.
我原本计划去德国，安定下来，然后再考虑这些棘手的问题。但看到这个年轻人，就像，哦，突然间我爱上了他，我想和他在一起。所以我不在乎环境如何。
And so what was it that changed your mind?
那么，是什么让你改变了想法？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
If he was someone who gave up, I wouldn't have pursued it. But I liked his persistence. That's what worked.
如果他是个会放弃的人，我就不会和他在一起了。但我喜欢他的执着。那才是奏效的地方。
Manaf stops translating and turns to me.
马纳夫停止了翻译，转向我。
That's a good tape.
那段录音真好。
And so, before you know it, Tarek and Hadil are planning a future together. But as with tens of thousands of other refugees in Greece, those plans involve gaining passage across multiple national borders, none of which show any promise of opening.
于是，不知不觉中，塔里克和哈迪尔开始规划两人的未来。但正如希腊数万名其他难民一样，这些计划涉及跨越多个国家边境，而没有哪一个显示出开放的希望。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Basically we are in a bit of a tough situation. Her parents are in Germany. And I need to see them. If I didn't see them, they won't approve this marriage.
基本上我们陷入了困境。她的父母在德国。我需要见他们。如果我见不到他们，他们就不会同意这桩婚事。
Marriage, [ARABIC].
婚姻，[阿拉伯语]。
They will not marry her to me.
他们不会把她嫁给我。
Tarek tried to get across the border himself once, with some smugglers-- no luck. It's not Hadil's parents are totally opposed to the relationship. It's just customary that they have to meet him first. But they aren't the only members of Hadil's family with opinions on this. In fact, she was traveling with family. She had them there with her at EKO Camp.
塔里克曾试图独自带着走私者过境——没成功。哈迪尔的父母并非完全反对这段关系。只是按照习俗，他们必须先见见他。但并不是只有哈迪尔家的人对这段关系有意见。事实上，她当时是和家人一起旅行的。在EKO营地时他们也在那儿。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
My sister and my aunt.
我的姐姐和姨妈。
Do they know about your relationship?
她们知道你们的关系吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC] Yes, they do.
[阿拉伯语交谈] 是的，她们知道。
Do they approve?
她们赞成吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
They don't approve? Oh no. What do you say to them? Have you tried to convince them?
她们不赞成？哦，不。你对她们说了什么？你试过说服她们吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I spoke so many times to them, tried to convince them. But they completely seemed to be against the idea.
我和她们谈了很多次，试过说服她们。但她们看起来完全反对这个想法。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
The problems are many I think. One of them is the fact that I spend more time with him than I do with them.
我认为问题很多。其中一个原因是我花在他身上的时间比花在她们身上多。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
And B, how people would see us around the camp.
还有，营地里的人会怎么看我们。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
It's the way he touches me and holds me. He's very affectionate and very romantic, which I love very much. But to them, they're saying to me hold on a second. There's nothing formal between the two of you. So to people, it might seem a bit out of order.
还有他碰我、抱着我的方式。他非常热情且非常浪漫，我很喜欢。但对她们来说，她们会对我说：“等等。你们之间又没有正式关系。”所以对外人来说，这可能看起来有点不守规矩。
So they're worried it's going to look scandalous?
所以她们担心这看起来会很丢人？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Yes, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
And finding privacy isn't exactly easy at a refugee camp, especially this camp, which is the size of a highway rest stop-- because again, it is a highway rest stop. Tarek says he went as far as to procure a secret tent for them, their own private tent that nobody knows about. I asked him, when shopping for a secret tent, what are the criteria you're looking for? Has to look like all the other tents, he said, so it doesn't stand out. That's smart.
在难民营里找到隐私并不容易，尤其是这个营地，它的大小跟高速公路休息区差不多——因为再说一次，它确实就是个高速公路休息区。塔里克说他甚至想办法为他们弄到了一个秘密帐篷，一个没人知道的私人帐篷。我问他，在挑选秘密帐篷时，你的标准是什么？他说，必须看起来和其他帐篷一样，这样才不会显眼。真聪明。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I love her very much. And those people won't stand in our way. Our love is stronger than this country that's blocking the border.
我非常爱她。那些人不会阻挡我们的路。我们的爱比阻挡边境的国家还要强大。
Wow, you should be a poet sir.
哇，先生，你该当诗人。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
He writes poetry.
他会写诗。
You do? I could tell.
真的吗？我看得出来。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Yeah, he writes lots of poems and recites them to me.
是的，他写了很多诗，还背给我听。
We should really--
我们真的应该——
I asked Tarek if he would read us one of his love poems at some point.
我问塔里克下次能不能给我们读一首他的情诗。
Not right now, this second.
不是现在这一秒。
I figured we'd just do it when we came back the next day. But then when we did go back the next day, our fixer went to find them and came back alone, with some news.
我想我们第二天回来时再录就好。但当我们第二天真的回去时，我们的向导去找他们，却一个人回来了，带回了一些消息。
What, are you kidding? Hold on one second. Wait-- wait-- wait-- wait.
什么，你在开玩笑吗？等一下。等等——等等——等等。
Our fixer, Ammar, said he had found Tarek all by himself in the tent, deeply upset.
我们的向导阿马尔说，他在帐篷里只发现了塔里克一个人，非常难过。
He's very furious right now because they took his girlfriend or fiance so whatever, yeah.
他现在很愤怒，因为他们带走了他的女朋友或未婚妻，随便吧，是的。
The sister and aunt did?
姐姐和姨妈带走的？
Yeah, the sister and the aunt took Hadeah-- Hadeah?
是的，姐姐和姨妈带走了哈迪尔——哈迪尔？
Hadil, but yeah, she was gone. Tarek wouldn't talk to me about it. He said no more recording. So Ammar sat with him in the tent for a long time, and finally convinced him to spill out the whole story.
哈迪尔，对，但她已经不见了。塔里克不愿跟我谈这个。他说不再录音了。所以阿马尔在帐篷里陪了他很久，最终说服他吐露了整件事。
Maybe he's drunk right now. He looks like drunk. So he told me that the aunt had bring like four men and attack him and beat him-- beat him. He looks like this.
也许他现在喝醉了。他看起来像醉了一样。他告诉我，姨妈带了大概四个男人袭击了他，还打了他——打了他。他看起来像这样。
Bent over.
弯着腰。
Yeah, just like-- yeah-- yeah. But there's no marks. There's no-- there is one mark here.
对，就是——是的——是的。但没有痕迹。没有——这里有一个痕迹。
On his elbow?
在他的手肘上？
Yeah, big one. It's just-- yeah-- yeah.
对，很大的一块。只是——是的——是的。
So the uncle--
所以叔叔——
He don't want to talk about it.
他不想谈论那个。
OK.
好的。
They went to go smuggling.
他们去偷渡了。
To go smuggling?
去偷渡？
Yeah, of course.
对，当然。
That is, her family took her with them to get smuggled across the Macedonian border so they could go north to the rest of Europe.
也就是说，她的家人带着她去偷渡过马其顿边境，好让他们能去北部的欧洲其他地方。
He's completely broken. He's completely--
他彻底崩溃了。他彻底——
I learned the rest of the story later. It wasn't just that Tarek and Hadil were all huggy and kissy around the camp. Hadil and her family are Christian. Tarek's Muslim. Hadil had only started wearing a headscarf when Tarek asked her too, as a first step toward converting for him. And the family was not cool with this.
我后来了解了故事的其余部分。不仅仅是因为塔里克和哈迪尔在营地里搂搂抱抱。哈迪尔和她的家人是基督徒。塔里克是穆斯林。哈迪尔只有在塔里克要求下才开始戴头巾，作为向他改宗的第一步。而家人并不接受这个。
Plus, this plan to get smuggled into Macedonia had already been underway for a while. And Hadil was suddenly saying, no, I'm staying behind with Tarek. And so they pried her out of there, beat Tarek up, bundled everybody into a bunch of cabs, and headed off to meet with a smuggler.
而且，通过偷渡进入马其顿的计划其实已经筹划一段时间了。哈迪尔当时突然说：“不，我要留在塔里克身边。”于是他们把她从那儿拉走了，打了一顿塔里克，把所有人打包塞进出租车，出发去见走私者了。
Tarek, alarmingly, told the police. He reported them, to keep them from leaving, which he is totally unrepentant about, except he feels bad that the smuggler got arrested. The plan was foiled, so the family turned around and headed south to a different camp. And they were gone.
塔里克惊人地报了警。他举报了他们，防止他们离开，对此他毫不后悔，但他觉得让走私者被捕心里有点过意不去。计划失败了，所以家人掉头向南去了另一个营地。他们就这么走了。
And this is where I figured the story would end. Tarek didn't want to talk to me anymore. And then a couple of days later I was at a different camp interviewing some folks with Manaf, the translator, when Ammar, our fixer who had talked with Tarek, interrupted us.
我还以为故事会到此结束。塔里克再也不想跟我说话了。几天后，我正在另一个营地和马纳夫（翻译）采访一些人，我们的向导阿马尔中断了我们。
Do you feel like the foreign media is trying to cover up the talents of refugees or-- say what?
你觉得外国媒体是否在掩盖难民的天赋或者——你说什么？
Just a second.
等一下。
Oh, yeah-- yeah-- yeah.
哦，对——对——对。
I need to talk to you, and Manaf too, just for a second.
我需要跟你谈谈，也和马纳夫谈谈，就一下。
We walk a few feet away. It's about Tarek, Ammar says. My first thought is, oh no, he's tried to kill himself, which I know sounds dramatic. And that's not what happened. Ammar says Tarek has heard from Hadil. She and her family are planning to head back to Turkey the next day, and that he needs to get to her, to get her out of there. He needs a car he says. Ammar tells him, "I don't have a car. I'm a refugee like you."
我们走开几步。阿马尔说，是关于塔里克的事。我的第一反应是，哦不，他自杀未遂，我知道这听起来很戏剧化。但这没发生。阿马尔说塔里克收到了哈迪尔的消息。她和家人计划第二天回土耳其，他必须去找她，带她离开那儿。他说他需要一辆车。阿马尔告诉他：“我没有车。我和你一样也是难民。”
"Yes," says Tarek, "but you hang out with those journalists. Maybe they can help?"
“是的，”塔里克说，“但你和那些记者混在一起。也许他们能帮忙？”
We had heard that driving refugees around could get you in trouble with the police. There was no way we were going to do that. But then I did do something that I'm not proud of, something that, if I had thought about it a little more, I would not have done. In the next moment I heard myself say, maybe I can get him some money for a taxi. Reporters aren't supposed to get involved like this in their stories. We're supposed to observe, not intervene.
我们听说开车送难民可能会惹上警察的麻烦。我们绝不可能那么做。但后来我还是做了一件我并不引以为傲的事，如果我多考虑一下，我就不会做了。下一刻，我听到自己说，也许我可以给他弄点钱坐出租车。记者不应该介入他们的故事。我们应该观察，而不是干预。
Looking back, it was a mistake. But in that moment, every reason I could think of not to help them seemed small, and almost cruel. I handed Ammar 100 euros. We all agreed he should tell Tarek it was from him and Manaf.
回头看，这是一个错误。但在那一刻，我能想到的每一个不帮忙的理由都显得很渺小，甚至近乎残忍。我递给阿马尔100欧元。我们都同意他应该告诉塔里克，这是他和马纳夫给的。
I never saw Tarek. Apparently he was so happy he did a little dance. He picked up Hadil at a cafeteria near where her family was staying and brought her with him back up north to a camp near the Macedonian border. After that, I wasn't worried about ethics. I was worried about Tarek and Hadil. What if Hadil's family found them and beat Tarek up again? At the very least, they'd have to be worried sick not knowing where Hadil is. Also, I don't even know these people. I don't know if this is what's best for them, for her.
我再也没见过塔里克。显然他高兴得跳了一小段舞。他在哈迪尔家人住处附近的餐厅接到了她，带她回到了北边靠近马其顿边境的营地。在那之后，我不担心伦理问题了。我担心的是塔里克和哈迪尔。如果哈迪尔的家人发现了他们又把塔里克打一顿怎么办？至少他们肯定会因为不知道哈迪尔在哪儿而担心得要命。另外，我甚至根本不了解这些人。我不知道这对他们、对她来说是不是最好的选择。
But I've talked with Tarek and Hadil on the phone since then, and they both said things are as good as they could possibly be right now. For one thing, they're married. They had a Muslim wedding and a Christian wedding. And Tarek says he even got some money together to pay a lawyer to help them get the marriage sanctioned in Greece.
但我后来和塔里克、哈迪尔通了电话，他们都说现在的情况好得不能再好了。首先，他们结婚了。他们举办了穆斯林婚礼和基督教婚礼。塔里克说他甚至凑了钱请了一名律师，帮助他们在希腊认可这段婚姻。
Hadil's aunt and uncle and sister never did go to Turkey. According to Tarek, they actually managed to get farther north in Europe, illegally. It's not that they're OK with the relationship, but now that it's official, they feel like they have to go along with it. Hadil's parents, though, are totally on board with it now.
哈迪尔的姨妈、姨夫和姐姐最终没有去土耳其。据塔里克说，他们竟然非法成功地深入了欧洲北部。他们并不是对这段关系没意见，但既然关系已经正式化了，他们觉得只能顺从。不过，哈迪尔的父母现在完全支持他们了。
Mostly when we hear about luck in the refugee camps, it's bad luck. But of course with so many people, something has to go right for somebody. It's just the law of averages. And Tarek and Hadil beat the odds in a ridiculous way. Even just meeting each other was a slim possibility, let alone his convincing her to give him a chance and convincing a bunch of near strangers to kick him 100 euros so he could get her back.
当我们听到难民营里的运气时，通常都是坏运气。但当然，这么多人在一起，总会有好事降临在某些人身上。这就是概率法则。塔里克和哈迪尔以一种不可思议的方式战胜了胜率。光是他们相遇的可能性就微乎其微，更别提他劝说她给他一个机会，以及劝说一群近乎陌生的人给他凑了100欧元让他把她接回来。
A few weeks after all this, my fixer Ammar was texting with Tarek. And Tarek said, "The most ridiculous thing of all is that all these feelings of love that you have in your heart, the big sacrifices you have made and the unexpected problems, all come down to a taxi fare. It's a bastard of a feeling when you're racing against time and it's not on your side."
这一切发生几周后，我的向导阿马尔在给塔里克发短信。塔里克说：“最荒谬的是，你心中所有的爱意、你所做的巨大牺牲以及那些意想不到的麻烦，最终都归结为一张出租车费。当你与时间赛跑且命运站在对立面时，那真是一种该死的感觉。”
Sean Cole. Act two, Thank You for Smoking.
肖恩·科尔。第二幕，“谢谢你的烟”。
People don't have a lot of money in the refugee camps. To explain people's financial situation, Joanna Kakissis, NPR's reporter in Greece who's producing these two episodes on the refugee camps with us, she explained to me that these refugees from Syria and the Mideast that we've all seen arriving on boats in Greece, she explained that they came in several distinct waves. The first wave--
难民营里的人没什么钱。为了解释人们的财务状况，Joanna Kakissis，NPR在希腊的记者，正与我们一起制作这两集关于难民营的节目。她向我解释说，我们看到的那些叙利亚和中东难民乘船抵达希腊，是分几个不同浪潮的。第一波——
So in early 2014 when I first started following the story, everyone I met was fairly well off. I mean--
所以在2014年初，当我开始关注这个故事时，我遇到的每一个人都相当富有。我的意思是——
All the refugees coming through.
所有的难民都经过这里。
Right. And they had paid something like between 3,000 and 5,000 euros to buy fake passports or fake IDs and fly to Germany or Sweden or wherever they were headed.
是的。他们支付了大约3000到5000欧元来购买假护照或假证件，飞往德国、瑞典或他们要去的地方。
5,000 euros is about $5,500 American.
5000欧元大约是5500美元。
And so we're talking about people who are cardiologists, people who are geophysicists, people who are big corporate managers.
所以我们谈论的是心脏病专家、地球物理学家、大企业经理这样的人。
Then the second wave arrived. This is last year, 2015. And it arrived because another route from Greece into the rest of Europe opened up, what they called the Balkan route. You didn't have to pay for a smuggler. You could just walk north out of Greece using maps that people were sharing on WhatsApp. Or much easier, you could take a bus.
然后第二波浪潮来了。这是去年，2015年。它的到来是因为从希腊通往欧洲其他地方的另一条路线开了，也就是所谓的“巴尔干路线”。你不需要支付给走私者。你可以直接沿着人们在WhatsApp上共享的地图向北走出希腊。或者更简单，你可以坐巴士。
So this route was actually much, much cheaper. You know, it was just a matter of buying bus tickets from one place to the other. And that's why you saw so many people coming, because suddenly it was less expensive.
所以这条路线实际上便宜得多。你知道，只需要从一个地方买到另一个地方的票就行了。这就是为什么你看到那么多人来，因为突然之间成本降低了。
And so what kind of people were you seeing then?
那么那时你看到的是什么样的人？
Then that's when you started seeing schoolteachers, shop owners, barbers. I mean, like the best way to put it is that people with just not that much money.
那时你开始看到学校老师、店主、理发师。我的意思是，最好的说法就是，没有多少钱的人。
And so these were the people, when the border to the rest of Europe closed this March, these were the people who got stuck in these refugee camps. Most of them are middle class and working class families who carry the equivalent of $1,000 or $2,000, and definitely did not have enough to spring for $3,000 to $5,000 per person for a smuggler and a fake passport.
所以这些人，当今年三月通往欧洲其他地方的边境关闭时，就是这些被困在难民营里的人。他们大多数是中产阶级和工人阶级家庭，随身带着相当于1000或2000美元的钱，绝对没有足够的钱为每个人支付3000到5000美元去请走私者买假护照。
So, they arrived without much money, and now it's been nearly five months. So to survive, lots of people get money from family overseas, wired to them, Western Union, to spend on essentials. And you can see what that means at our next stop. This is a camp that's been built on the grounds of an abandoned psychiatric hospital. It's kind of a spectacular setting at the base of Mount Olympus. So you have this snow capped mountain looming, surrounded by thick forest. Yellow paint is peeling off the old hospital buildings on the grounds-- 1,300 people living in white military tents, the Yazidi, which is a religious minority from Iraq.
所以他们到的时候没带多少钱，现在已经快五个月了。为了生存，很多人从海外亲戚那里汇钱过来，通过西联汇款，花在必需品上。你可以在我们的下一站看到这意味着什么。这是一个建在一个废弃精神病院场地上的营地。它位于奥林匹斯山脚下，景色壮观。你有一座积雪覆盖的山峰隐约可见，周围环绕着茂密的森林。废弃医院大楼上的黄色油漆正在剥落——1300人住在白色的军用帐篷里，他们是雅兹迪人，伊拉克的一个宗教少数群体。
And unlike the other camps that we visited, the people here are looking for a country that's going to take all 1,300 of them. They don't want to be split up. Before the borders closed, they'd been trying to join other Yazidis who'd already made it to Germany. One of our producers, Miki Meek, visited.
与我们访问过的其他营地不同，这里的人正在寻找一个能接收全部1300人的国家。他们不想被拆散。在边境关闭之前，他们一直试图与已经到达德国的其他雅兹迪人团聚。我们的制片人之一米奇·米克去访问过。
This camp is in the middle of nowhere. The closest town is about 16 miles away. Very soon after the Yazidis arrived, people began setting up their own town in the camp, slipping right back into their old jobs.
这个营地位于偏远地区。最近的城镇大约有16英里远。雅兹迪人抵达后不久，人们就开始在营地里建立自己的城镇，直接重操旧业。
A group of men who used to be barbers back in Iraq lined up chairs by an electrical outlet outside. Haircuts go for 2 euros. Eyebrow and beard threadings go for 1.
一群以前在伊拉克做理发师的男人在外面找了个电源插座排队放椅子。剪发2欧元。修眉和修胡须1欧元。
Three women on the other side of the camp made an oven out of a metal barrel they covered with mud. They're bakers. You can buy five pieces of naan for  1 euro.
营地另一边的三个妇女用一个桶做了一个烤箱，外面糊了泥。她们是面包师。你可以用1欧元买五张馕饼。
But the most popular spot is in a makeshift shop along a dirt path at the front of the camp. A guy named Ahmad built it. He threw it together with UNHCR tarps and old doors and shutters he found in the abandoned psychiatric hospital. He made an awning out of a thick green sleeping bag from the military. Ahmad pointed out the most popular item in his shop.
但最受欢迎的地方是营地前方土路边上的一个临时商店。一个叫艾哈迈德的家伙建的。他用联合国难民署的防水布、从废弃精神病院找到的旧门和百叶窗胡乱拼凑起来的。他用一个军用厚绿色睡袋做了个遮阳棚。艾哈迈德指出了他店里最受欢迎的商品。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
The most selling item obviously is cigarettes. People buy cheap brands like President, Bond, Royale, and Gold. They go each for 2 and 1/2 euros.
最畅销的商品显然是香烟。人们买像President、Bond、Royale和Gold这样的廉价品牌。每包售价2.5欧元。
A pack?
一包？
A pack, yes. So I know it's wrong. It's not healthy. But it's a very good way to calm you down.
一包，是的。我知道这不对。不健康。但这是让你冷静下来的好方法。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
We here, we live in continuous stress, unknown future.
我们在这里，生活在持续的压力下，未来未知。
People need a cigarette. People need to smoke right now.
人们需要香烟。人们现在就需要抽烟。
Exactly. So people need to smoke, to get on with things.
完全正确。所以人们需要抽烟，来继续生活。
So you are smoking super lights, President. This is your brand?
所以你在抽President特醇。这是你的品牌？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I'll sell you two, two packs for 4.50 euros.
我卖给你两包，4.5欧元。
So you're selling, selling even in an interview.
所以你即使在采访中也在卖东西。
Smoking is such a part of life for men at the camp that wherever we looked, someone was smoking or offering us cigarettes. Sometimes I'd look over at my interpreter Manaf during an interview, and he'd be holding a lit cigarette in each hand. It was too rude to say no.
抽烟在营地的男人们生活中占据很大一部分，无论我们看向哪里，总有人在抽烟或给我们递烟。采访时我有时会看向我的翻译马纳夫，他两手都拿着点燃的香烟。拒绝太不礼貌了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Lighter. Lighter.
打火机。打火机。
Give me lighter.
给我打火机。
Give you lighter.
给你打火机。
At first I thought Ahmad must be the one guy who figured out how to hustle and make money in this situation.
起初我以为艾哈迈德一定是唯一一个想出如何在这种情况中做生意赚钱的家伙。
Give me euro.
给我欧元。
He was always pacing in front of his shop, always selling, charismatic. Then I learned he's hardly making any profit. I'm pretty sure he's running the world's only cigarette charity.
他总是在店前踱步，一直在卖东西，很有魅力。后来我才知道，他几乎没赚什么利润。我敢肯定他在经营着世界上唯一的香烟慈善店。
Ahmad pays to take a bus down to town a couple times a week where he loads up on cigarettes. Total cost per pack, including his bus fare, 2.35 euros a pack. And then at the camp, he turns them around and sells them for only 2.50 euros. That's just a 15 cent profit, barely covers his costs.
艾哈迈德每周付钱坐车去镇上几次，在那里装满香烟。每包总成本，包括车费，2.35欧元。然后回到营地，他转手只卖2.5欧元。那只有15欧分的利润，勉强覆盖成本。
He gives good deals for fruits and vegetables too. They get three meals a day from the Greek government, but they're like TV dinners, nothing fresh. So people stop by right after meals are distributed--
他在水果和蔬菜上也给很好的优惠。他们从希腊政府那里每天领三餐，但就像冷冻餐一样，没有新鲜的。所以人们在饭后分发完就过来——
Tomato-- tomato.
番茄——番茄。
--to make up things like eggplants, cucumbers, bananas.
——买茄子、黄瓜、香蕉之类。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
This bag of sugar as well, 89 cents.
这袋糖也是，89欧分。
Ahmed said he sells sugar for what it costs, because it's too much of a necessity. Everyone needs it for their tea.
艾哈迈德说他按成本价卖糖，因为它是必需品。每个人都需要它泡茶。
But there's a thing I started noticing. A lot of people would walk up to Ahmed during the day, silently hand him money, and then walk away from his shop without taking anything.
但我开始注意到一件事。很多人白天走到艾哈迈德那里，默默递给他钱，然后没拿任何东西就走开了。
There's a man right here and he just walked up and is paying Ahmad 2 and 1/2 euros.
这儿有个人，他刚才走过来，给了艾哈迈德2.5欧元。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Obviously I trusted him with the money. I wasn't there, in the shop. This month comes in, picks up what he wants. Then he goes--
显然我信任他拿着钱。我当时不在店里。这钱送过来，他拿走他想要的。然后他走了——
So he's paying--
所以他在付——
[INAUDIBLE].
[无法辨认]。
This is when I realized, this is not a normal store. Ahmad can leave it open and unattended, and people can take what they want on credit. They don't even leave him a note. They just tell him later.
这时我意识到，这不是一家普通的商店。艾哈迈德可以把它开着无人看管，人们可以赊账拿走他们想要的。他们甚至不给他留字条。他们只是稍后再告诉他。
Everyone is low on cash, even the most powerful person in the camp, the religious leader, Sheikh Nuri. Even he has to get stuff for free from Ahmad. I watched him stop by the shop after lunch.
每个人都缺现金，连营地里最有权势的人、宗教领袖努里谢赫也是。连他也不得不从艾哈迈德那里免费拿东西。我看着他午饭后到店里。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I took some spices, onions, and tomato for free. So basically the way it goes, if I need something, I would come to the shop and take it. We're all like this. We're barely surviving. Most of us will have to borrow from Ahmad. Ahmad is ready-- Ahmad is ready to help us. Without him, I think we don't know what we would do basically.
我免费拿了一些香料、洋葱和番茄。基本上就是这样，如果我需要什么，我会来店里拿。我们都这样。我们勉强维持生存。我们大多数人都得向艾哈迈德借钱。艾哈迈德准备好了——艾哈迈德准备好帮助我们。没有他，我想我们根本不知道该怎么办。
This camp is different from the others we visited. The Islamic State targeted these Yazidis for extinction, invaded their home in the mountains of northern Iraq, and began a mass extermination campaign, killed the men, kidnapped the women and girls, and made them sex slaves, sent the kids to ISIS training camps. Maybe you remember, these are the people President Obama helped save with airstrikes in 2014. They're survivors fleeing genocide. They're used to looking out for each other.
这个营地与我们访问过的其他营地不同。伊斯兰国将这些雅兹迪人定为灭绝目标，入侵了他们位于伊拉克北部山区的家园，开始了一场大规模种族灭绝运动，杀死了男人，绑架了妇女和女孩作为性奴隶，把孩子送进ISIS训练营。也许你记得，这就是奥巴马总统在2014年通过空袭拯救的人民。他们是逃离种族灭绝的幸存者。他们习惯于互相照顾。
Ahmad said it's ingrained in them. So when people come to his shop and they can't pay, he's fine with that. He tells them to pay what they can when they can if they can. He carries a little black notebook in his fanny pack, listing each family and what they owe him.
艾哈迈德说这是他们根深蒂固的传统。所以当人们来他店里付不起钱时，他没意见。他告诉他们，如果能付，就在能付的时候付。他在腰包里装着一个黑色小笔记本，列出每个家庭和他们欠他的钱。
What does it say?
上面写着什么？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Name, Hadeato. 2 euros previously owed, plus 4 euros today for vegetables.
名字，Hadeato。之前欠2欧元，加上今天买蔬菜的4欧元。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Marwan, another name, 13 euros owed in the past. 3 euros tomato, 2 euros onion.
马万，另一个名字，之前欠13欧元。3欧元番茄，2欧元洋葱。
So aren't you're just losing a lot of money?
所以你不是亏了很多钱吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I started the shop with 500 euros as a capital. Now I have lent the equivalent of 200 euros.
我用500欧元的资本开了店。现在我借出了相当于200欧元的钱。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
If we continue like this, obviously I can't run my shop much longer.
如果这样继续下去，显然我的店开不了多久了。
Back in Iraq, Ahmad also had a shop selling groceries and other stuff. And he says he made about $250 a day in profit. Now he's making $11 a day. He spends $8 on food for his family and $3 on cigarettes.
在伊拉克，艾哈迈德也有一家卖杂货和其他东西的店。他说他每天赚大约250美元的利润。现在他每天只赚11美元。他花8美元给家人买吃的，3美元抽烟。
He's here with his wife and seven kids. His store back home had backgammon, chess, and cards that men would come play at night for money. Ahmad still runs a tiny gambling den. It's in the back of his shop, lit by a couple of rechargeable UNHCR lamps that hang from the ceiling at night.
他带着老婆和七个孩子在这儿。他家乡的店里有西洋双陆棋、国际象棋和牌，男人们晚上会来玩钱。艾哈迈德依然经营着一个小赌局。就在店后面，晚上由几盏挂在天花板上的可充电联合国难民署灯照亮。
I sat next to a young guy, 25 years old, named Haider. He says he kills about four hours every day in the back of Ahmad's shop.
我坐在一个叫海德尔的25岁年轻人旁边。他说他每天在艾哈迈德店后杀四个小时。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
He starts laying down cards.
他开始摊牌。
Did you just win?
你刚才赢了吗？
I just scored the lowest. Basically he's won the game.
我刚好得了最低分。基本上他赢了比赛。
The 50 cents everyone put into play all goes toward a bag of mixed vegetables for the winner. Or like in Haider's case, he just uses the winnings to retire some of his debt with Ahmad.
每个人投入的50美分都给了赢家买一袋混合蔬菜。或者像海德尔这样，他直接把赢来的钱用来偿还艾哈迈德的债务。
How much money did you have when you came to Greece?
你到希腊时带了多少钱？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
So I had 500 euros.
我带了500欧元。
What about now?
现在呢？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
You're standing up and pulling money out of your pocket. So how much? How much do you have there? 3 euros. You have 3 euros.
你站起来正在从口袋里掏钱。那是多少？你有多少？3欧元。你有3欧元。
Yes-- yes.
是的——是的。
I basically have 3 euros to last me three days. So Ahmad here is here to help me if I needed anything.
我基本上只有3欧元撑三天。所以艾哈迈德在这儿，如果我需要什么他会帮我。
This was an unusually unprofitable day for Ahmad. He was out 240 euros. He borrowed 100 euros to buy produce and given out another 140 euros on credit to different families. Also, he didn't sell much.
这对艾哈迈德来说是不寻常的亏损日。他亏了240欧元。他借了100欧元买农产品，又以赊账形式给了不同家庭140欧元。此外，他卖的东西也不多。
Couldn't you, for a while if you had to, stop taking stuff on credit just till you got a little bit more stable?
如果你不得不这么做，你不能暂时停止赊账，直到你稍微稳定一点吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I think my philosophy in the shop is to be able to help others. And stopping giving things on credit is simply out of the question. Because as long as I know that I can support the minimum. So if need of my family, then the rest would obviously have to be giving as a form of assistance to others, even if they couldn't pay.
我认为我的经营哲学是能够帮助他人。停止提供赊账是根本不可能的。只要我知道我能支持最低限度。所以，如果需要给家人，其余的显然必须作为一种援助提供给他人，即使他们付不起钱。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Then I would shut down the shop and just become a customer myself.
那我还不如关了店，自己变成个顾客。
He told me he'd rather go out of business than stop giving credit to people at the camp.
他告诉我，他宁愿倒闭，也不愿停止给营地里的人赊账。
Miki Meek. Coming up, John Oliver, Larry Wilmore, Trevor Noah, you're now on notice. Refugees are entering the fake news business. Tremble at the competition in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
米奇·米克。接下来，乔恩·斯图尔特、拉里·威尔莫、特雷弗·诺亚，你们现在被警告了。难民们正在进入假新闻行业。当我们的节目继续时，从芝加哥公共广播电台，颤抖着迎接挑战吧。
This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's it's our second show from the refugee camps in Greece. This week, you don't have to live like a refugee. We have stories of people trying to get on with their lives even though they are stuck in a refugee camp.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的不同故事。今天是我们从希腊难民营播出的第二期节目。本周，你不必像难民一样生活。我们有关于人们试图继续生活，即使他们被困在难民营的故事。
And before we go any further with our show, I just want to say an incredible team has built an interactive tour of the camps that we visited with little movies and photos and three dimensional architectural renderings. And it pains me, as a radio producer, to say the following words, to admit that seeing something might actually give you a fuller view of it, but it's true. They did a great job capturing all kinds of things about daily life that you can't actually see over the radio. It's at our website thisamericanlife.org. And this brings us to Act Three of our program, Act Three, Last Resort.
在节目继续之前，我只想说，一个不可思议的团队制作了我们访问过的营地的互动导览，有小电影、照片和三维建筑效果图。作为一名广播制片人，说出以下词句让我很痛苦，承认亲眼所见可能真的会让你有更全面的认识，但这是事实。他们出色地捕捉到了日常生活中你无法通过收音机听到的各种事物。在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上。这带我们进入了节目的第三幕，第三幕，“最后手段”。
So as we talked about a little bit in last week's program, the Greek government's response to the refugee crisis has had a lot of heart. The refugees are treated with respect. They're treated with warmth in many places that we visited. But it hasn't gone so smoothly.
正如我们在上周节目中稍微提到的，希腊政府对难民危机的应对很有诚意。难民受到了尊重。在我们访问过的许多地方，他们受到了热情的对待。但这过程并不顺利。
Two government agencies have had trouble sorting out who would do what. It's still disorganized. Housing conditions for the refugees nearly everywhere are substandard. One official from an international organization that is working with the Greek government told me at one point, "It's 57,000 refugees." And they said, "Compare that to the refugee situations that they deal with elsewhere." Jordan has 700,000 refugees. Lebanon has over a million. Turkey has over 2 million. "57,000 refugees, this person said, "that's a soccer game in Europe. It shouldn't be this hard."
两个政府机构在分工上遇到了麻烦。依然是一团糟。几乎所有地方的难民住房条件都低于标准。一个与希腊政府合作的国际组织的一位官员曾对我提到：“那是5.7万名难民。”他说，“把它与他们在其他地方处理的难民情况相比。”约旦有70万难民。黎巴嫩有超过一百万。土耳其有超过两百万。“5.7万名难民，此人说，“那只是一场足球比赛的观众。不应该这么困难。”
So there is a camp trying to set the gold standard for what refugee camps can be in Greece. It's near a village called Myrsini on the coast of the Ionian Sea, a four hour drive west of Athens. LM Village it's called. It's a former resort, an actual beach vacation resort that went bankrupt seven years ago-- 38 bungalows, painted bright orange and yellow, each with its own bathroom and electricity and kitchenette, a little plot of grass all facing the sea with a secluded beach just for them. One of our producers said when she saw it the first time, "With a little TLC and some water in the pool, we'd all want to stay there."
所以，有一个营地试图为希腊的难民营树立黄金标准。它位于爱奥尼亚海海岸的一个叫米尔西尼的村庄附近，距离雅典西面四小时车程。它被称为LM村。这是一个前度假村，一个七年前破产的真正海滩度假胜地——38个平房，漆成亮橙色和黄色，每个都有自己的浴室、电力和简易厨房，还有一小块面向大海的草地，有专属于他们的僻静海滩。我们的一位制片人说，当她第一次看到它时：“只要稍微维护一下，往游泳池里注点水，我们大家都会想住在那儿。”
So this March right after the borders closed, this beach resort refugee camp opened basically because one person, the mayor of that area, willed it into existence. Joanna went there.
所以今年三月边境关闭后，这个海滩度假村难民营之所以成立，基本上是因为一个人，该地区的市长，凭意志让它变成了现实。乔安娜去了那里。
This mayor is different from other Greek mayors in one important way. This mayor's from Syria. His name's Nabil Morad. He actually made history a couple of years ago when he became the first immigrant elected mayor in Greece. And back then Nabil was focused on the typical things that mayors think about-- you know, fixing roads and street lights, marketing the region's strawberries, improving tourism.
这位市长在一点上与其他希腊市长不同。这位市长的家乡是叙利亚。他的名字叫纳比勒·莫拉德。几年前他创造了历史，成为希腊首位当选市长的移民。当时纳比勒专注于市长通常考虑的典型事务——你知道，修理道路和路灯，推销该地区的草莓，改善旅游业。
But as the refugee crisis unfolded in Europe and he saw so many Syrians displaced and homeless, it really got to him. He took one look at the empty beach resort in his municipality, LM Village, and he thought, why not? Why not bring them here to this beach resort?
但随着难民危机在欧洲展开，他看到如此多的叙利亚人流离失所、无家可归，这真的触动了他。他看了一眼他辖区内空置的海滩度假村，LM村，他想，为什么不呢？为什么不把他们带到这个海滩度假村来呢？
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
You need to provide shelter in an elegant way, in a good way. You don't just stick people in tents.
你需要以优雅的方式，以一种好的方式提供庇护。你不能仅仅把人塞进帐篷里。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
That's the message we, in this camp, want to send to the rest of Europe, that when the refugees get to you, don't forget they're people. They need to be treated with respect and with care. That's why the success of this camp is so important to me.
那是我们在这个营地想传达给欧洲其余部分的信息，当难民到达你们那儿时，别忘了他们也是人。他们需要受到尊重和照顾。这就是为什么这个营地的成功对我来说如此重要。
Nabil is the Greekest Syrian I've ever met. He moved here 27 years ago, married a Greek, served in the Greek army, works as a doctor, and runs a clinic with his Greek doctor wife, in Greece. He's so fluent in Greek he often speaks in old world slang my grandmother used to use.
纳比勒是我见过希腊化程度最高的叙利亚人。他27年前搬到这里，娶了一个希腊妻子，在希腊军队服役，担任医生，并与他的希腊妻子在希腊共同经营一家诊所。他希腊语说得非常流利，经常使用我祖母过去使用的老式俚语。
Nabil knew he was the best advocate for a better lifestyle for refugees. To rally locals around his cause, Nabil, in a kind of Mr. Smith Goes to the Ionian Sea way, held a town meeting in Maria Palaiologos cafe in Myrsini. That's how small a town this is, the cafe doesn't even have a name. It's just Maria Palaiologos cafe. At least 100 people packed inside, and more spilled out onto the street.
纳比勒知道他是难民更好生活方式的最佳倡导者。为了让当地人支持他的事业，纳比勒以一种《史密斯先生去华盛顿》式的风格，在米尔西尼玛丽亚·帕莱奥洛戈斯的咖啡馆举行了一次市民会议。这就是这个小镇有多小，咖啡馆甚至都没有名字。它只是玛丽亚·帕莱奥洛戈斯咖啡馆。至少有100人挤在里面，更多的人溢出到街上。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
Some of them had created an atmosphere of fear and terror about the refugees, that they're criminal, heathens, lazy.
他们中的一些人制造了关于难民的恐惧和恐怖气氛，说他们是罪犯、异教徒、懒汉。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
An old man told me about he was a buy a shotgun to keep them from getting into his home. Others were talking about rapes.
一位老先生告诉我他要买一把霰弹枪来防止他们闯入他的家。其他人则在谈论强奸。
Nabil told them he wanted to bring only families, Syrian families, people like him-- no single men, no Afghans, no Pakistanis, just Syrian families. He knew his audience. He also told the group it wouldn't cost the municipality anything to host the Syrian families. The state would cover everything but trash collection.
纳比勒告诉他们，他只想带家庭，叙利亚家庭，像他一样的人——没有单身男人，没有阿富汗人，没有巴基斯坦人，只有叙利亚家庭。他了解他的听众。他还告诉大家，接待这些叙利亚家庭不会给市政带来任何成本。州政府将承担除垃圾收集之外的一切。
A week after the meeting at the cafe, he called on his municipal council to vote on the plan. It really went over. Out of 26 council members, only one voted no.
咖啡馆会议一周后，他召集了他的市政委员会对该计划进行投票。真的通过了。在26名议会成员中，只有一人投了反对票。
Here's how desperate the Greek government is to get people set up in camps. It took them less than a week. In fact, just four days after the vote, buses filled with Syrians, over 300, arrived at the abandoned beach resort. Nabil and his family were there, some local councilors too. Remember, Nabil had promised that only families would come live at the resort. Nabil hoped that was true.
这就是希腊政府让人们入住营地的急切程度。用了不到一周。事实上，在投票后仅四天，载满叙利亚人的巴士，超过300人，抵达了废弃的海滩度假村。纳比勒和他的家人在那里，还有一些当地议员。记住，纳比勒承诺只有家庭会来度假村居住。纳比勒希望这是真的。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
Well, we were very nervous because we didn't know who got in. Since things were done in a hurry, I didn't know what to expect. Who will I find on the buses?
嗯，我们当时非常紧张，因为我们不知道谁会进来。既然事情办得很匆忙，我不知道会发生什么。我会在巴士上发现谁？
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
The whole village had gathered. There was some that came out of love. And there was a group against my decision for the center, waiting to see so they could protest more. They wanted to reaffirm their lies using the first image of the refugees. They always say the same.
整个村庄都聚集了。有些人是出于爱而来的。还有一群人反对我的中心决定，等着看好借机抗议更多。他们总是利用难民的第一印象来重申他们的谎言。他们总是说同样的话。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
If they are men, they will steal, kill, and rape. When they saw, just as I did, the children that were coming out of the buses first, at this point I relaxed. The crowd started hugging the children. Some of them started smiling.
如果他们是男人，他们会偷窃、杀人和强奸。当他们和我一样看到先从巴士上下来的孩子时，这时我放松了。人群开始拥抱孩子们。他们中的一些人开始微笑。
Nabil remembers meeting a baby who was just five days old.
纳比勒记得见到一个只有五天大的婴儿。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
She was in a little basket. I got close to the family. When I went close, I said in Arabic, "Hello, how are you doing." They understood who I was. The mother took the baby, put it in my hands. I melted. I melted. My knees were shaking from holding her.
她在篮子里。我靠近那个家庭。当我走近时，我用阿拉伯语说：“你好，你们好吗？”他们明白我是谁。母亲抱起婴儿，放进我怀里。我融化了。我融化了。我的膝盖因为抱着她而颤抖。
[SPEAKING ARABIC] You were moved I said.
[阿拉伯语交谈] 你被感动了，我说。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Very, very.
非常非常感动。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
I understood her mother who gave birth alone in a hospital and didn't even know the language, with no one of her people there to wish well for the child in Arabic.
我理解她的母亲，她独自在医院生下孩子，甚至不懂语言，周围没有自己人可以用阿拉伯语为孩子送上祝福。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
That's why I was so moved.
这就是我如此感动的原因。
This camp is meant to be better than other camps, and it is. There are kids on BMX bikes. There are soccer and basketball games. There's a trampoline and ping pong. Men play chess on a lawn with a view of the sea. The beach is to the west, so there's a sunset on the water every day.
这个营地旨在比其他营地更好，也确实如此。有骑着BMX自行车的孩子。有足球和篮球比赛。有蹦床和乒乓球。男人们在面向大海的草地上玩国际象棋。海滩在西面，所以每天都有水上日落。
Sometimes a group of friends, women, dress up in beautiful printed velour dresses that cover them from head to toe, just to go for a walk on the paved empty road lined with ornate old fashioned lampposts.
有时一群妇女朋友会打扮成穿着漂亮的印花丝绒裙子，从头到脚遮住自己，只是为了在装饰着华丽复古路灯的铺设空旷道路上散步。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
The Syrians told me that after finally making it to Greece and sleeping in tents, pitched on streets, in field, in the mud, they were relieved to get here and rest on beds and actual homes with their own bathrooms. One woman told me she hadn't had a full night's sleep in months until she got here.
叙利亚人告诉我，最终来到希腊并睡在泥土、田野、街道上搭建的帐篷里后，他们能来到这里休息在床上，住在有自己浴室的真正房子里，感到很宽慰。一位妇女告诉我，直到来到这里之前，她已经几个月没有睡过一个完整的觉了。
The camp has been open now for four months. And Nabil never expected how demanding it would be. He's the one who recruited volunteers, organized doctors and midwives, called in immigration lawyers, got supplies donated. And then when the refugees arrived, he realized a critical oversight. He brought hundreds of people who only speak Arabic to a rural area where the only other person for miles who also spoke Arabic was him, Nabil, which meant that he's the person who explains that the food is not rotten or where to buy Halal meat or which direction Mecca is.
这个营地已经开放四个月了。而纳比勒从未想到它会如此苛刻。他是那个招募志愿者、组织医生和助产士、召集移民律师、筹集物资的人。然后当难民抵达时，他意识到了一个严重的疏忽。他把数百名只会说阿拉伯语的人带到了农村地区，而方圆几英里内唯一也说阿拉伯语的人就是他，纳比勒，这意味着他得解释食物没坏，或者去哪里买清真肉，或者朝哪个方向是麦加。
The Syrians ask him to help them get papers to go to Germany. They ask him if EU leaders are going to fly them out of the local airport. Sometimes when someone needs to get to Athens for asylum interviews and doesn't have a ride, he'll buy the bus ticket himself. He gets calls from the camp all the time, day or night. The Syrians ask him everything, including-- because remember, Nabil is not only the mayor, he's also a doctor-- they ask him lots of questions about their health.
叙利亚人请他帮忙弄文件去德国。他们问他欧盟领导人会不会用当地机场把他们接走。有时当某人需要去雅典进行庇护面试却没车时，他会自己买车票。他随时会接到营地的电话，白天或晚上。叙利亚人问他所有事情，包括——因为记住，纳比勒不仅是市长，还是医生——他们问他很多关于健康的问题。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Like here he is walking around the camp just saying hello to two women. One of them says her friend is very tired. The friend says her body and throat hurt. Nabil checks her throat.
就像他现在在营地走动，只是向两个妇女问好。其中一个说她的朋友非常累。朋友说她的身体和喉咙疼。纳比勒检查了她的喉咙。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
You need antibiotics, he says, and sends her to the camp medical station. This is all on top of him having to run his clinic full time. And being mayor is a big job. He manages 22 towns in his municipality. He calls this camp, LM Village, his 23rd town.
你需要抗生素，他说，并把她送到了营地医疗站。这还要在他全职运营自己的诊所之上。而且当市长也是一份大工作。他管理着辖区内的22个城镇。他把这个营地，LM村，称为他的第23个城镇。
I live in Greece, and I can tell you that the refugee crisis has created a whole new sense of obligation. Whenever I interview Greeks about the refugees or when I talk to my relatives and friends and neighbors, one thing always comes across. People want to help them. There's a word in Greek, [GREEK]. There's no equivalent in English. But in essence it means be generous and do good. It's a point of national pride, of Greek character and culture.
我住在希腊，我可以告诉你，难民危机创造了一种全新的义务感。每当我采访希腊人关于难民的情况，或者当我与亲戚、朋友和邻居交谈时，有一件事总会浮现。人们想帮助他们。希腊语中有一个词，[希腊语]。英语中没有对应的词。但本质上它意味着慷慨并做善事。这是国家骄傲的一点，是希腊性格和文化的一点。
But after a six year economic crisis so many Greeks are broke or barely getting by, Greeks are also thinking it's a very real possibility that I could soon be destitute myself. And how can I help then? How can we help so many displaced people now living with us?
但在六年的经济危机后，如此多的希腊人破产或勉强维持生计，希腊人也在考虑，我很快自己也会变得一贫如洗是一个非常现实的可能性。那时我怎么能帮得上忙？我们怎么能帮助这么多现在和我们生活在一起的流离失所的人？
And you see both these impulses, [GREEK] and fear, in Myrsini, the town next to LM Village. On the one hand, the locals I spoke with said most people don't have a problem with the Syrians. They're happy that these families with little kids are secure and safe. The vice president of the town, for example, told me he spends all day with the Syrians and he sees real needs there.
你在米尔西尼，LM村旁边的城镇，既看到了这种冲动，[希腊语]，也看到了恐惧。一方面，我交谈过的当地人说大多数人对叙利亚人没有问题。他们很高兴这些带着小孩的家庭能够安全保障。例如，镇副主席告诉我，他整天和叙利亚人在一起，他在那儿看到了真正的需求。
But he also sees needs all around him, even his own neighbor, a 70-year-old woman he's known his whole life. She's now so broke she's washing her hair with Tide. Or there's Nikos who's 43, and like a quarter of Greeks, unemployed. He used to work in construction. When I'd met him, he'd been out of work for a while and he didn't have health insurance. And he expressed real and understandable resentment.
但他也在他周围看到了需求，甚至是他的邻居，一位他认识一辈子的70岁老妇人。她现在破产到用汰渍洗头。或者43岁的尼科斯，和四分之一的希腊人一样失业。他过去从事建筑工作。当我见到他时，他已经失业一段时间了，也没有健康保险。他表达了真实且可以理解的怨恨。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
I don't have the money to pay. So I'll have to stay uninsured. If something happens to me and I have to go to the hospital, I will owe money.
我没有钱付。所以我不得不保持没保险。如果我发生了什么事必须去医院，我就会欠债。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
A foreigner doesn't have these problems. It's not fair.
外国人没有这些问题。这不公平。
Refugees can go to the hospital for free. Sometimes I've noticed that local resentment toward the camp is less personal and more outright xenophobic.
难民可以免费去医院。有时我注意到当地人对营地的怨恨较少是针对个人，更多是直接的仇外心理。
Occasionally the rumors get really overblown. My producer Robyn Semien and I spoke to Alexandra Altouni. She's the councilwoman who voted against the camp in the first place.
偶尔谣言变得非常夸大。我的制片人罗宾·塞米恩和我采访了亚历山德拉·阿尔图尼。她就是那位起初投票反对营地的议员。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
I heard of what they say is, well, you know. You guys, you Greeks are supposed to take care of us. We're not going to do anything here because we don't have to. We gave them a place to stay, to eat. The Red Cross is helping them. We took them to the doctors, gynecologists.
我听到了他们的说法，嗯，你知道。你们，你们希腊人应该照顾我们。我们不需要在这里做任何事，因为我们不必。我们给了他们住的地方、吃饭的地方。红十字会在帮助他们。我们带他们去看医生、妇科医生。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
We've even given them birth control pills so they won't have more kids. So I ask, because theoretically there are women and children here, why do they need birth control pills? Because lots of things have been told. There are lots of rumors going around.
我们甚至给了他们避孕药，这样他们就不会有更多的孩子。所以我问，因为理论上有妇女和儿童在这里，为什么他们需要避孕药？因为有人传了很多话。外面流传着很多谣言。
Rumors that involve sex and money.
涉及性和金钱的谣言。
Do you believe these rumors that the women are prostitutes?
你相信这些关于妇女是妓女的谣言吗？
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
It could be a lie. But I really want to know why they need birth control pills if they don't have men. But you know, this is what I think. I think--
这可能是个谎言。但我真的很想知道，如果她们没有男人，为什么需要避孕药。但你知道，我是这么想的。我想——
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
--if they're coming from a war zone and theoretically they're damaged people and they're worried about what's next for them, why do they even care about sex? Why should that even be an issue for them?
——如果她们来自战区，理论上她们是受损的人，她们担心接下来的事，为什么她们甚至关心性？为什么那甚至应该是她们的一个问题？
It's not true that most of the women are there without their husbands. And of course it's not true that they're prostitutes. Alexandra resents Nabil for bringing the refugees here. She sees the camp as a betrayal to the Greeks who supported him.
绝大多数妇女不是没有丈夫就在那儿。当然，她们是妓女也不是事实。亚历山德拉因为纳比勒把难民带到这里而对他感到不满。她认为营地是对支持他的希腊人的背叛。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
We didn't see him as a Syrian when we voted for him. We supported him more than we would have a Greek, a Greek Greek, a real Greek. How can I say it? We saw him as Greek. He's not Greek. He's a guest here.
我们投票给他时并没有把他看作叙利亚人。我们支持他甚至超过支持希腊人，希腊人，真正的希腊人。我怎么说呢？我们把他看作希腊人。他不是希腊人。他是这里的客人。
Four months in, many of the Syrians still seem to like and appreciate Nabil. I've been there four times, and for the most part, the Syrians are OK with the camp, just like the Greeks who live around it. There is also a small but very vocal minority that's frustrated and angry and blaming Nabil.
四个月了，许多叙利亚人似乎仍然喜欢并感谢纳比勒。我去过那儿四次，在很大程度上，叙利亚人对营地没什么意见，就像住在它周围的希腊人一样。还有一个很小但非常大声的少数群体感到沮丧和愤怒，并责备纳比勒。
To give you a sense of how intense this can be, the first week in June, I stopped by the camp late one Sunday night with my interpreter, Roula. They heard her accent, and then they knew that she's also Syrian. She was instantly surrounded by a crowd.
为了让你感受到这有多激烈，六月的第一周，我曾在某个星期天深夜带着我的翻译鲁拉去过营地。他们听到了她的口音，然后他们就知道她也是叙利亚人。她瞬间被人群包围。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
They wanted to talk about Nabil, to complain about him.
他们想谈谈纳比勒，投诉他。
There's lots of mosquitoes here. Can you do something about it? All of the children here, they have plenty of rashes because of mosquitoes.
这里蚊子很多。你能做点什么吗？这里所有的孩子因为蚊子都有皮疹。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Would he accept that if his children would live like this.
如果他的孩子住在这里，他会接受吗？
Someone else complains they found worms in the water tank on the property. There had been a protest. Some refused to eat. They said Nabil didn't do enough. Also--
有人投诉说他们在水箱里发现了虫子。有人抗议。有些人拒绝进食。他们说纳比勒做得不够。还有——
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Someone broke his leg. And they called in Dr. Nabil, and he was upset as well because they called him.
某人摔断了腿。他们叫了纳比勒医生，他也因为他们叫他而心烦。
Are there people other than Dr. Nabil you can call here? Because the army has doctors.
除了纳比勒医生，这里还有其他人你可以打电话吗？因为军队有医生。
He said that Dr. Nabil always told him that there's no doctors in this country.
他说纳比勒医生总是告诉他这个国家没有医生。
He said Nabil told him there were no doctors in this country? The military doctors are right there, every Monday. There's a midwife that comes every Friday.
他说纳比勒告诉他这个国家没有医生？军事医生就在那里，每周一。每周五都有助产士来。
I get Nabil can't be everywhere at once, but that's not what this group wants to hear.
我明白纳比勒不能同时出现在所有地方，但这群人不想听到这个。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
The only thing that we would like from Dr. Nabil is just not to think himself he's done the best thing in the world by bringing us here.
我们从纳比勒医生那里想要的唯一一件事，就是不要觉得他通过把我们带到这里做出了世界上最好的事。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I mean, it's good. It's good. But still, we just asked him for the water the other day and he said "Oh, if you don't like it here, just go back to Athens."
我是说，这很好。这很好。但依然，前几天我们刚找他要水，他说“哦，如果你不喜欢这里，就回雅典去。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
There is a saying in Greek and in Arabic, do a good deed and then throw it into the sea, meaning don't expect a reward. And Nabil didn't expect a reward, but he also didn't expect to be berated. When the Syrians found worms in the water tank, Nabil checked it out right away and fixed it. But the complaints that this somehow signified that he didn't care about the Syrians, that got to him.
希腊语和阿拉伯语里有一句谚语，做一件善事，然后把它扔进大海，意味着不要期待回报。纳比勒没有期待回报，但他也没想到会被责骂。当叙利亚人在水箱里发现虫子时，纳比勒立即检查了它并修好了。但投诉这在某种程度上意味着他不关心叙利亚人，这让他难受。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
Yeah, actually it pissed me off. And there were instances like that where everyone's like, it's your fault. It's your fault. It's your fault. This perception that I'm always at fault when doesn't go right for them, that upset me so much that for a time I didn't go for days because it stressed me out to go.
是的，实际上这让我很火大。还有那样的例子，每个人都说，是你的错。是你的错。是你的错。当事情对他们不顺利时，总认为是我在错，这让我非常沮丧，以至于有一段时间我好几天都没去，因为这让我压力很大。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
And now I just go to families that I feel like I can talk to, people who listen to me and who I can listen to, not people who have just decided what they want to think and don't want to hear me out and just want me to do what they want to do-- every little thing.
现在我只去那些我觉得能谈话的家庭，那些听我说话的人，以及我能听他们说话的人，而不是那些已经决定他们想怎么想、不想听我解释，只想让我做他们想做的事——每一件小事的人。
[SPEAKING GREEK]
[希腊语交谈]
They thought that because I'm the mayor, I can solve everything.
他们认为因为我是市长，我能解决一切。
"Of course they need more than they have," he says. "But it's not fair for them to make demands. A small group does this," he says, tells him, "You owe us."
“当然他们需要的比他们拥有的多，”他说。“但他们提出要求是不公平的。一小群人就这样做，”他说，告诉他，“你欠我们的。”
He looks upset telling me this. He fidgets with a string of worry beads. He wants to be understood. He wants you to understand. So he switches to English.
他告诉我这些时看起来很难过。他摆弄着一串念珠。他想被理解。他想让你理解。所以他换成了英语。
I give everything. I want just a good words. And one thank you, nothing else. I am one of them. You feel sad. For me, they make me sad, a lot of times, very sad.
我付出了一切。我只想要一句好话。以及一个谢谢，什么都没有。我是他们的一员。你感到难过。对我来说，他们让我难过，很多时候，非常难过。
Sometimes when he's so exhausted he can't sleep and he's running through all the things he didn't have time to do, he'll remember how simple life was when he was just a good doctor, before he was mayor, before he wanted to change anything. So I ask him, "Why bother? Why bother doing all this?" And he tells me, "I don't want to be that guy who just sits around and says everything sucks and does nothing. Even this is better than that."
有时当他疲惫不堪无法入睡，回想他没有时间做的所有事情时，他会记得他在只是一名好医生时生活是多么简单，在他成为市长之前，在他想改变任何事情之前。所以我问他：“为什么费心？为什么要费心做这一切？”他告诉我：“我不想成为那个只坐着说一切都糟透了却什么都不做的人。即使是这样也比那样更好。”
Joanna Kakissis. She normally reports about the refugee crisis for NPR News from Greece. She's currently writing a book about Syrian families who come from the same neighborhood and are now living in Germany.
乔安娜·卡基西斯。她通常为NPR新闻报道希腊的难民危机。她目前正在写一本书，关于来自同一个社区现在生活在德国的叙利亚家庭。
Act Four, Take Another Little Piece of My Heart. So one night at the camp at the beach resort, LM Village, a bunch of kids and men walked up to Joanna and Robyn Semien from our staff. And one of the men started talking fast, kind of panic struck.
第四幕，“再多给我的一点心”。所以在一个晚上，在海滩度假村营地，LM村，一群孩子和男人走近我们员工的乔安娜和罗宾·塞米恩。其中一个男人开始说话很快，有点恐慌。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
He said his wife had had a medical problem a few days before, and they called an ambulance, but the ambulance did not come. And she was still at the camp. Here's Robyn.
他说他的妻子几天前有医疗问题，他们叫了救护车，但救护车没来。她还在营地里。这是罗宾。
As this man talked about his wife, I looked around the crowd for her. And she's so low key, I didn't see her walk up. She stood off to the side, quiet, purple hijab matching her purple long sleeved T-shirt. Her name's Nasem, Nasem Alsayed Ali.
当这个男人谈论他的妻子时，我在人群中寻找她。她很低调，我没看到她走过来。她站在一边，安静，紫色头巾搭配紫色长袖T恤。她的名字叫纳赛姆，纳赛姆·阿尔赛义德·阿里。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Once we started talking, she pulled the neckline of her shirt down, just a little, to show me part of a scar.
一旦我们开始交谈，她把衬衫领口向下拉了一点，露出疤痕的一部分给我看。
Can you show me where?
能给我看看在哪里吗？
A perfect right angle, like a bracket, or a greater than sign saying, this direction to her heart, it's greater than the other stuff. The scar is big, clearly new.
一个完美的直角，就像一个括号，或者一个“大于”符号，显示这个方向通向她的心，它比其他东西更重要。疤痕很大，显然是新的。
Nasem had heart surgery in Turkey in January. She found out about the heart problem, a hole, back home in Idlib in Syria. But there were no good surgeons left. They'd all fled or been killed. Syrian president Bashar al-Assad has been targeting doctors and medical workers. So she and her husband and her three kids went to Turkey.
纳赛姆一月份在土耳其做了心脏手术。她在叙利亚伊德利卜的家里发现了心脏问题，一个洞。但没有优秀的医生留下来。他们都逃跑了或者被杀了。叙利亚总统巴沙尔·阿萨德一直针对医生和医务工作者。所以她和丈夫以及三个孩子去了土耳其。
After the surgery, her doctors gave her a strong warning. Whatever you do, don't get pregnant, for two years. Your heart may not be able to handle it. You might die. They told her to rest and come back in a month.
手术后，她的医生给了她一个严厉的警告。无论你做什么，两年内不要怀孕。你的心脏可能承受不了。你可能会死。他们告诉她休息，一个月后再回来。
She and her family did not go back in a month. They had a chance to get on a boat to go to Greece, so they did that. But by the time Nasem got to LM Village, she'd already been hospitalized twice. They had to drain fluid from the surgery wound.
她和她的家人一个月后没有回去。他们有机会乘船去希腊，所以他们就那样做了。但当纳赛姆到达LM村时，她已经被送进两次医院。他们不得不从手术伤口排出积液。
At LM Village, she started having trouble, again. Her left arm was in pain. Sometimes she couldn't open her left hand.
在LM村，她又开始遇到麻烦了。她的左臂疼痛。有时她打不开左手。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
When I went to the hospital here, they just took a blood test for me. And then two hours later, they came, they said oh, you're pregnant. You have a baby.
当我到这里的医院时，他们只给我做了血液测试。然后两小时后，他们来了，说哦，你怀孕了。你有个宝宝。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
And I said, no, no, I'm not pregnant. And then the [INAUDIBLE], they said, you are pregnant. And it was quite shocking for me that I was pregnant.
我说，不，不，我没怀孕。然后[无法辨认]，他们说，你怀孕了。这对我来说相当令人震惊。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Then I was like oh my god, I don't know what to do. I don't know what to do. And then they asked me, "Do you want to keep the baby?" And I said no. And they said yes, they're happy that they heard that because--
那时我想天哪，我不知道该怎么办。我不知道该怎么办。然后他们问我，“你想留住这个孩子吗？”我说不。他们说好，他们听到这个很高兴，因为——
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
--keeping of the baby, that means it's dangerous for my life. This is what they told me at the hospital. So I don't have a choice as well.
——留住这个孩子，意味着这对我的生命来说很危险。这就是他们在医院告诉我的。所以我也没有选择。
Her husband agreed. They had to think first about Nasem's health. The hospital made an appointment for an abortion the following week. Someone at the camp arranged a taxi. They got a friend to stay with their kids.
她的丈夫同意了。他们必须首先考虑纳赛姆的健康。医院为接下来的一周预约了堕胎。营地有人安排了一辆出租车。他们找了个朋友照顾他们的孩子。
But their youngest is a toddler. She's two. You know two.
但他们最小的孩子是个幼儿。两岁。你知道两岁。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
She was screaming and shouting and crying. Like we didn't know what happened with her. We couldn't just leave her and go. We didn't know what's wrong.
她在尖叫、大喊、大哭。像我们不知道她发生了什么事。我们不能就这么留下她走掉。我们不知道有什么问题。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
We said fine-- fine. Let's take her with us. My husband went to the car and said, can you please hold it a minute?
我们说好——好。带上她一起。我丈夫走到车前说，能请你等一下吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
So I just was trying to get her dressed. And the time that we got her dressed, the car was gone.
所以我当时只是试图帮她穿好衣服。我们让她穿好衣服时，车已经走了。
Oh no.
哦不。
He didn't wait. It's kind of our fault in a way as well that we were late, but--
他没等。某种程度上这也是我们的错，因为我们晚了，但——
It's hard to get a ride as a refugee in Greece. A lot of people think driving a refugee is illegal. They couldn't take another cab because they had no money for another cab. The one they missed was paid for by donations. They don't speak Greek, so they can't even call the hospital to explain and make another appointment. No one at the hospital speaks Arabic.
在希腊作为难民很难搭车。很多人认为开车载难民是非法的。他们不能再叫一辆出租车，因为他们没钱。第一辆是靠捐款支付的。他们不懂希腊语，所以他们甚至不能打电话给医院解释并另作预约。医院里没人说阿拉伯语。
Nasem has a brother who lives in Holland who is fluent in Greek, Greek and Arabic. So sometimes she'll get him on the phone. But you can see how that's not ideal.
纳赛姆有个在荷兰生活的哥哥，希腊语和阿拉伯语都很流利。所以有时她会给他打电话。但你可以看出那并不理想。
When I met Nasem, she was two or three months pregnant. Different doctors had told her different things. She was still having pains in her arm from her surgery.
当我见到纳赛姆时，她已经怀孕两三个月了。不同的医生告诉她不同的事。她的手臂因手术依然疼痛。
I went to her house at the camp. My interpreter Roula and Nasem and I sat at the kitchen table. Her husband was there too, pacing. They've been married 11 years. They have three kids. He was losing his mind over all this. We had a long talk about everything that's been on their mind since all this started, including how they got here.
我去了她在营地的房子。我的翻译鲁拉、纳赛姆和我坐在厨房桌旁。她的丈夫也在那儿，踱步。他们结婚11年了。他们有三个孩子。这一切让他疯了。我们长谈了关于这一切开始以来他们心头的一切，包括他们如何来到这里的。
Did you talk about using birth control? Was there a way to get birth control?
你们谈过使用避孕措施吗？有没有办法获得避孕措施？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I couldn't take the birth control because I couldn't take any medication after the operation. And we were planning to do with something inside.
我不能用避孕药，因为手术后我不能吃任何药。我们当时计划做点内部的。
A diaphragm.
隔膜。
A diaphragm. But we didn't have time when I was in Turkey.
隔膜。但我在土耳其时没时间。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Dr. Nabil and many people, they told my husband, man, you're fast, why you didn't hold them a second for getting her pregnant.
纳比勒医生和许多人，他们告诉我的丈夫，伙计，你太快了，你为什么不忍住让她怀孕呢。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
But the thing is they tried their best, like he was-- so they were trying kind of using--
但事实是他们尽了最大努力，就像他——所以他们尝试了——使用——
Oh, I'm stopping the tape. Things got a little explicit. So I just rephrased what her husband told me. OK, back to the tape.
哦，我停止录音了。事情变得有点露骨。所以我重述了他丈夫告诉我的。好了，回到录音。
It's the pull out method. He was always doing this method. But he doesn't know how-- like, we don't know how it happened.
是体外射精法。他总是用这个方法。但他不知道怎么——就像，我们不知道它怎么发生的。
What about condoms?
那避孕套呢？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
He doesn't like to use condoms some days.
他有些日子不喜欢用避孕套。
You're blushing.
你在脸红。
Yes.
是的。
You're blushing.
你在脸红。
Not so surprising universal truth-- many men who love their wives do not love condoms.
并非如此令人惊讶的普世真理——许多爱妻子的男人不喜欢避孕套。
So, after Nasem and her husband missed their first abortion appointment, they eventually did get another one.
所以，在纳赛姆和她丈夫错过第一次堕胎预约后，他们最终得到了第二次。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I went again. I finally could find appointment. I want again there, but they said that they could not do the operation now because the baby is big.
我又去了。我终于找到了预约。我去了那里，但他们说他们现在不能做手术，因为孩子太大了。
Oh no.
哦不。
She got this news just two weeks after the first appointment. She was still in her first trimester, but the hospital she was at was so small, they couldn't safely handle the abortion. The very thing the heart surgeons warned her against, pregnancy might be too much for her heart, and here she was, pregnant, and being told, basically, hope for the best.
她在第一次预约两周后得到这个消息。她还在怀孕头三个月，但她在的那家医院太小了，无法安全处理堕胎。心脏外科医生警告她的事情，怀孕对她的心脏可能负担太重，而这里她怀孕了，被告知，基本上，祈祷好运吧。
This sounds so dangerous. What you're describing, it sounds very dangerous. How scary is it for you? How scared are you?
这听起来太危险了。你所描述的，听起来非常危险。对你来说有多可怕？你有多害怕？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Sometimes I just cannot sleep all in the night. But what I do is I pray. I pray for God to help me.
有时我整晚都睡不着。但我所做的是祈祷。我祈祷上帝帮助我。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
And I pray to tell him, please God, if I sleep, wake me up the next day. Don't just let me sleep for the rest of my life.
我祈祷告诉他，上帝请，如果我睡着了，第二天叫醒我。不要让我睡着度过余生。
Do you ever wake your husband up and tell him I can't sleep, I can't sleep?
你曾经叫醒你丈夫告诉他我睡不着吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Yes, of course. I mean sometimes he would tell me to be patient, be patient and pray.
是的，当然。我是说有时他会叫我耐心点，耐心点，祈祷。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Just be patient with the pain.
对疼痛保持耐心。
A high risk pregnancy is scary under normal circumstances, not to mention a very high risk pregnancy. Nasem was in a refugee camp. No one spoke her language. Money was tight. She couldn't get around on her own. And she couldn't get medical advice she could trust.
高风险怀孕在正常情况下就很可怕，更不用说极高风险怀孕了。纳赛姆身处难民营。没人说她的语言。钱紧。她无法自己四处走动。她得不到她能信任的医疗建议。
A third of the women in this camp were pregnant. I talked to others. Nobody was happy to be having a baby here. But Nasem's case was the most extreme.
这个营地里三分之一的妇女怀孕了。我和其他人谈过。没有人很高兴在这里生孩子。但纳赛姆的情况是最极端的。
If there's a way to have an abortion now, you still want one?
如果现在有办法堕胎，你依然想吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
No, I prefer not to have abortion. I prefer to go and stay in the hospital to give birth.
不，我宁愿不堕胎。我宁愿去医院呆着，生孩子。
Now you want the baby?
现在你想要这个孩子了？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Yes.
是的。
I came back from a week of reporting in Greece and couldn't stop thinking about Nasem. Whatever I was doing, she was still at a refugee camp waiting out a high risk pregnancy.
我从希腊报道了一周后回来，无法停止想纳赛姆。无论我在做什么，她依然在难民营等待着高风险怀孕。
I talked to an OB-GYN in New York and described the situation. She said a pregnancy like this requires weekly monitoring by a specialist, sometimes daily depending on what's happening, and that the delivery or C-section would require a cardiologist to be there as well.
我与纽约的一位产科医生交谈，描述了这种情况。她说这样的怀孕需要专家每周监测，有时每天，取决于正在发生什么，分娩或剖腹产还需要心脏病专家在场。
I reached out to one of the midwives at the camp. She told me Nasem had finally had an abortion. I was surprised and a little freaked out. How? Where did she wind up? I called my interpreter Roula right away to get in touch with Nasem. I wanted to know if she was OK.
我联系了营地的一位助产士。她告诉我纳赛姆终于堕胎了。我很惊讶，有点吓坏了。怎么回事？她最后在哪儿？我立即打电话给我的翻译鲁拉去联系纳赛姆。我想知道她是否还好。
When Roula reached Nasem, she wasn't at LM Village. She was at a university hospital two hours away in the high risk pregnancy ward where she did not have an abortion. She was still pregnant.
当鲁拉联系上纳赛姆时，她不在LM村。她在两小时外的高风险产科病房，她没有堕胎。她依然怀孕。
Hi.
嗨。
It's nice to hear your voice again. Why are you in the hospital?
很高兴再听到你的声音。你为什么在医院？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
It had been a rough few days. She was bleeding and ended up here. It turned out to be a blood clot, which went away. And then they kept her for a few days longer. She wasn't sure why exactly, but she thought due to concerns with her heart.
那是艰难的几天。她正在出血，最终到了这里。结果是一个血栓，它消失了。然后他们又留了她几天。她不确定确切原因，但她认为是因为对她心脏的担忧。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
They told me that they should just lie down and not work, not carry anything.
他们告诉我应该躺着，不工作，不搬运东西。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
They told me that my situation is a bit not stable.
他们告诉我的情况有点不稳定。
When I asked Nasem if the doctor recommended she have an abortion, she told me she didn't know. She thought her pregnancy was as risky as it had always been, but she also wanted to get back to her family at the camp. I couldn't quite tell what was going on, and neither could she. So with her permission, I called the doctor. It took two weeks to get a hold of them.
当问纳赛姆医生是否建议她堕胎时，她告诉我她不知道。她认为怀孕和以前一样危险，但她也想回到营地的家人身边。我没能完全分辨出发生了什么，她自己也分辨不出。所以在她允许下，我打电话给医生。花了两个星期才联系上他们。
I would like to introduce myself. Hi, I am Charalampos Vitsas, obstetrician in General Hospital of Patras University in Greece.
我想自我介绍。嗨，我是查拉兰波斯·维萨斯，希腊帕特雷大学总医院的产科医生。
Dr. Vitsas treats women in the high risk pregnancies. The hospital is the best hospital in the area to handle Nasem's situation. It also has a cardiology department. Dr. Vitsas treated Nasem during the eight days she was there. She was the first woman from a refugee camp he's treated. I asked him, in different ways, how bad is this? Can Nasem survive having this baby? He said it's not black and white. She might survive. He'd heard about a similar case where the woman survived.
维萨斯医生治疗高风险怀孕妇女。这家医院是该地区处理纳赛姆情况最好的医院。也有心脏科。维萨斯医生在她呆的那八天里治疗了纳赛姆。她是他在治疗的第一位来自难民营的妇女。我用不同的方式问他，这有多糟糕？纳赛姆能生下这个孩子吗？他说这并不是非黑即白的。她可能会存活。他听说过类似病例，那名妇女活了下来。
In your professional opinion, do you think she should have an abortion?
从你的专业角度看，你认为她应该堕胎吗？
To be honest, no.
老实说，不。
No?
不？
No.
不。
But as we talked, it became clear that he thought "no" because he understood that's what Nasem wanted. It wasn't his medical opinion. He just assumed she'd never consider an abortion, for religious reasons. He didn't know about the missed abortion appointment in the other hospital, or that Nasem had had an abortion once back in Syria. He said they could barely communicate. She was in the hospital for over a week, and no one there spoke Arabic. He said even trying to tell her at the end of the week, you're OK. You can go now. Even that took 20 minutes with her brother on the phone, the one who speaks Greek helping translate.
但随着我们交谈，很明显，他认为“不”是因为他明白那是纳赛姆想要的。那不是他的医学观点。他只是认为她永远不会考虑堕胎，因为宗教原因。他不知道另一家医院错过的堕胎预约，也不知道纳赛姆在叙利亚曾堕过一次胎。他说他们几乎无法沟通。她在医院呆了一周多，没人说阿拉伯语。他说即使在周末试图告诉她“你还好，现在可以走了”，这也花了20分钟，她那说希腊语的哥哥在电话上帮忙翻译。
Hearing this kind of blew my mind. All you do when you're pregnant is go to a doctor every few weeks and talk about you. How are you feeling? What are you worrying about? How's your appetite? Every incremental, mind numbingly boring change is discussed.
听到这里让我脑子炸了。你怀孕时所做的只是每几周去看一次医生，谈谈你。你感觉怎么样？你在担心什么？你的食欲怎么样？每一个微小的、麻木的BORING变化都会讨论。
Nasem's in this super dangerous pregnancy, and when she finally got to see a doctor who specializes in high risk pregnancies and was in his care for a whole week, he said she asked him next to nothing. And he explained things using Google Translate on his phone hoping it made sense. It seemed tragic.
纳赛姆处于这种极其危险的怀孕中，当她最终见到一位专门研究高风险怀孕的医生并接受他照顾整整一周时，他说她问他几乎没什么问题。而他使用手机上的谷歌翻译进行解释，希望这说得通。这看起来很悲剧。
After I told him she was, in fact, open to the idea of an abortion, I asked the question again.
在他告诉他她事实上对堕胎的想法持开放态度后，我再次问了那个问题。
Do you think if you knew that she was open to the idea, even though she doesn't want one, do you think you might have asked her to consider maybe having one?
你认为如果你知道她持开放态度，即使她不想，你认为你可能会要求她考虑堕胎吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You do?
真的吗？
Yeah, because the condition is very high risk.
是的，因为这种情况风险非常高。
Huh.
呵。
Just to be clear, I'm not saying Nasem should have an abortion. I'm saying she deserves to have a conversation with a doctor where all the risks are discussed in detail and she can make an informed decision. Without that, a choice isn't a choice. It's a guess.
为了明确，我不是说纳赛姆应该堕胎。我是说她值得与医生进行一场详尽讨论风险的谈话，这样她才能做出知情决策。没有那个，选择就不是选择。那是个猜测。
Maybe the biggest problem with having a pregnancy like this, in a refugee camp, is no one person is tracking Nasem as she goes. I'm sure that's a problem with other urgent medical issues, but a pregnancy like Nasem's, she needs someone who will take this on, who will be with her for the whole nine months. She doesn't have that. As of August, she's six months pregnant, still at the camp, and still piecing it together without understanding most of what's being said to her, one worrying hospital visit to the next.
也许在难民营中这样怀孕的最大问题是没人跟踪纳赛姆的状态。我肯定那是其他紧急医疗问题的问题，但像纳赛姆这样的怀孕，她需要有人能承担这个任务，能在九个月里一直陪着她。她没有。截至八月，她怀孕六个月了，依然在营地，还在一筹莫展，没听懂大部分对她说的话，从一次令人担忧的医院之行到下一次。
Robyn Semien.
罗宾·塞米恩。
Act Five, Smile, You're On Handmade Camera. So when we were preparing to go to Greece, one of our producers, Sean Cole, was researching probably the best known refugee camp. It was at Idomeni. Right on the Macedonian border in the north. And it was like on the border. And it was vast, 15,000 people living there at its height, and not an official camp set up by the government. It was kind of a mess-- mud and people and protests and clashes with police and refugees throwing rocks and police firing tear gas. If you saw any pictures in the news of Greek refugee camps, chances are you were looking at Idomeni.
第五幕，“微笑，你在手工相机镜头前”。所以当我们要去希腊时，我们的制片人之一肖恩·科尔在研究可能是最知名的难民营。它在伊多梅尼。就在北部马其顿边境上。它就在边境。而且规模巨大，顶峰时有15000人住在那里，而且不是政府建立的官方营地。它有点像一团糟——泥泞、人和抗议，与警察冲突，难民扔石头，警察发射催泪瓦斯。如果你在新闻中看到任何关于希腊难民营的照片，很可能你看到的就是伊多梅尼。
But researching Idomeni, we hit upon this one piece of coverage that we found that was not like any of the others. And Sean got a little bit obsessed with it. Here he is.
但研究伊多梅尼时，我们找到了这篇报道，它与其他报道都不一样。肖恩对它有点着迷了。他在这儿。
Before we left for Greece, I had heard that a group of refugees at Idomeni were doing video news bulletins from the camp themselves, which was intriguing. They called it refugees.tv. But then when I went to watch the videos online--
去希腊前，我听说伊多梅尼的一群难民正在营地亲自做视频新闻简报，这很吸引人。他们称之为“难民.TV”。但当我上网看这些视频时——
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I'll just describe them. They're like the field reports you see on TV where the reporter's on the scene.
我来描述一下。就像你在电视上看到的现场报道，记者就在现场。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[叠加声音]
But in this case, the reporter is talking into a pretend microphone, like something a kid would make in an after school craft lesson. And also in the shot with him-- I mean obviously somebody is actually recording him. But within the shot is another guy who's just acting like he's the camera man, with a camera that is a block of wood with a plastic bottle tied to it. And with fake mic and camera in hand, they walk up to one person after another and say, in reporterly seriousness, "May I ask a few questions?"
但在这种情况下，记者是对着假麦克风说话，就像孩子在课后手工艺课上做的东西。而且和他一起出镜的——显然确实有人在录他。但镜头里还有另一个人，只是假装是摄像师，相机就是一块绑着塑料瓶的木头。手里拿着假麦克风和相机，他们走向一个人又一个人说，怀着记者般的严肃，“能问几个问题吗？”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Some people smile a little first. Everyone says sure, and politely answers.
有些人先笑了一下。每个人都说当然，并礼貌地回答。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
It just didn't match up with anything I think when I think of a refugee camp. Like it wasn't in the script. It was funny and surreal, and I loved them immediately. So when we finally got over there, I went and met them at the camp they had moved to after Idomeni was closed.
它与我想到难民营时想到的任何东西都不匹配。就像不在剧本里一样。它既滑稽又超现实，我立刻就喜欢上了。所以当我们最终到达那里时，我去见了他们，在伊多梅尼关闭后他们搬到的那个营地。
Hi. How are you? Basel.
嗨。你好吗？巴塞尔。
Mahmoud.
马哈茂德。
Great camera.
很棒的相机。
The guys with the fake camera and mic are Basel Alyatkan and Mahmoud Abdul Rahim. Basel's 30. He's from Damascus. Mahmoud's 24 from Aleppo. In their Penn and Teller duo, Mahmoud, the reporter, is the tall skinny one with his face to the crowd. Basel, squinting into a piece of wood, is shorter and chubby, and says almost nothing in the videos. But when I sat down on a blanket with them in the grass, Basel did most of the talking.
拿着假相机和麦克风的家伙是巴塞尔·阿亚特坎和马哈茂德·阿卜杜勒·拉希姆。巴塞尔30岁。他来自大马士革。马哈茂德24岁，来自阿勒颇。在他们的“潘恩和特勒”二人组中，马哈茂德，假记者，是那个对着人群的高个瘦子。巴塞尔，眯着眼对着一块木头，更矮且圆润，在视频里几乎不说什么。但当我坐在草地上的毯子上和他们交谈时，巴塞尔说了大部分话。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
He says they were just sitting around chatting one day about how there weren't as many camera crews around the camp as usual. And while they were talking, he started fashioning together this dummy microphone from some junk that was just lying around.
他说他们有一天只是坐着闲聊，谈论营地里的摄制组不如平常多了。当他们交谈时，他开始用放在那儿的垃圾拼凑这个假麦克风。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I had sort of a teacup--
我有一个茶杯——
He means a Styrofoam cup.
他是指泡沫塑料杯。
--and the lid of a sardines can. I fit it in, and we were just talking, normal conversation. And Mahmoud started talking, so I put this thing next to his mouth.
——还有个沙丁鱼罐头盖。我装了进去，我们只是在谈话，正常的对话。马哈茂德开始说话了，所以我就把这东西放在他嘴边。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
And I started switching between back and forth.
我也开始来回切换。
Switching back and forth the way interviewers do with a real microphone.
像记者用真麦克风那样来回切换。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
So I worked on the body of the camera with this piece of wood, this water bottle that you see attached to it, and then attached to it this wire and this sock to clean the lens.
所以我用这块木头做了相机机身，附上了你看到的这个水瓶，然后附上了这根线和这只用来擦镜头的袜子。
The lens, which is the cap of a plastic water bottle.
镜头，也就是塑料水瓶的盖子。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
And then we started talking how bad the media is.
然后我们开始谈论媒体有多糟糕。
Case in point, after they had jury rigged the mic and the wooden camera together, they ran off to, quote, unquote, "cover" their first big story. This was before anyone was even videoing them doing it. They were just goofing around.
比如，在他们把假麦克风和木头相机组装好后，他们跑去，引用，“报道”了他们的第一个大新闻。这还是在甚至没人拍他们之前。他们只是在胡闹。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
There was some children burning the tents in one area.
有些孩子在烧某个区域的帐篷。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
So Mahmoud and I ran up to them to start filming them up to show that this is what the media is interested in, to film the bad things. And then a group of media people saw us and they came to film us while--
所以马哈茂德和我就跑过去开始拍他们，以证明媒体感兴趣的就是这个，拍那些糟糕的事情。然后一群媒体的人看到了我们，他们跑过来拍我们，当——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So you were right.
所以你是对的。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
This is Mahmoud, the fake reporter.
这是马哈茂德，假记者。
And the fire brigade, the Greek fire brigade were trying to put out the fire. And I started saying the Greek brigade are putting out the fire outside--
希腊消防队试图扑灭火。我开始说希腊消防队正在扑灭外面的火——
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
--putting out the fire inside our hearts.
——扑灭我们心里的火。
From then on, they started filming their coverage, first on a cell phone camera. And then someone at a German NGO liked what they were doing and donated a real camera to the cause, just a little Panasonic. Their friend Mustafa is basically the entire crew.
从那时起，他们开始录制他们的报道，起初是用手机镜头。然后德国一个NGO的人喜欢他们正在做的，捐了一台真相机，只是个小松下。他们的朋友穆斯塔法基本上就是整个团队。
I'm the real cameraman.
我是真摄像师。
Mustafa speaks English. And their buddy Sameer has a laptop, so he uploads the videos to Facebook.
穆斯塔法说英语。他们的哥们萨米尔有台笔记本电脑，所以他把视频上传到Facebook。
One of the first videos they uploaded was the most classic hacky TV news cliche you could think of. Mahmoud does an on the spot report from a gale force wind storm, Pup tents are billowing around. He and Basel walk over to an unsuspecting interview subject, but you can barely hear them because, again, they're speaking into a piece of garbage.
他们上传的首个视频之一是你所能想到的最经典、老套的电视新闻。马哈茂德在疾风暴雨中进行现场报道，小帐篷在起伏。他和巴塞尔走过去找了一个没防备的采访对象，但你几乎听不清他们，因为，再次，他们对着一块垃圾说话。
It makes sense that these guys, and actually a lot of the refugees that we talked to, would have a problem with the media. You hear people say, we're living like animals here. Add to that a bunch of random camera crews and reporters roaming around, and they feel like animals in a zoo. Plus someone else is deciding what their story is and what it means. That must suck. So taking out the fake camera and mocking the news media was an antidote to that, for everybody. This is Basel again.
这些家伙，以及实际上我们交谈过的很多难民，对媒体有意见是有道理的。你听到人们说，我们在这里过得像动物。再加上一堆随机摄制组和记者游荡，他们觉得就像动物园里的动物。而且是别人决定他们的故事是什么、这意味着什么。那一定很烂。所以拿出假相机嘲弄新闻媒体对每个人来说都是解药。这是巴塞尔再次说的。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Seeing us doing this made sense because it spoke to them. It represented the truth of what's happening in the camp.
看着我们这么做是有意义的，因为它和他们对话了。它代表了营地正在发生的真相。
The truth being a bunch of people walking around with ridiculous contraptions?
真相就是一堆人带着荒谬的装置四处走动？
Yes.
是的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And pretty soon they got more ambitious. Instead of just poking fun at the media, they put on a full scale, Saturday Night Live type sketch aimed at the whole political circus of the refugee crisis, as they saw it.
很快他们就更有野心了。与其仅仅嘲笑媒体，他们开始策划一场全规模的、像《周六夜现场》风格的小品，针对他们所看到的整个难民危机政治马戏团。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Mahmoud, once again, is on the spot reporter saying, "New surprise from Refugees.tv, breaking news minute by minute." But this time a group of fake UN officials are stationed behind him, five men standing near a tiny square table with paper placards strung around their necks that say UN written in pen. A white board hung off to the side reads, UN Office of No Information and No Help For Refugees.
马哈茂德，再一次，成为现场记者说，“来自难民.TV的新惊喜，每分钟突发新闻。”但这回，一组假联合国官员站在他身后，五个人站在一张小方桌边，脖子上挂着纸标牌，上面用笔写着UN。挂在边上的一块白板上写着：联合国无信息、无难民援助办公室。
One of the five fake officials is Mustafa. Mahmoud approaches him, saying, "How can you help the refugees here that have been stuck for over 55 days-- 55 days-- and don't know what's going to happen to them? And the UN and the European Union haven't decided anything. They're saying there's a surprise today at the UN office. Can you tell us about it?
那五个假官员之一是穆斯塔法。马哈茂德接近他，说：“你如何帮助这里被困了超过55天——55天的难民？他们不知道会发生什么。联合国和欧盟还没决定任何事。他们说今天联合国办公室有个惊喜。你能告诉我们吗？”
Yeah, we have a surprise from our office, the new United Nations office. So we found a solution for the people. Now there is a new asylum program. We choose a country for you. We're going to choose for you Syria or Iraq, or Palestine if you want.
是的，我们有个惊喜，来自我们的办公室，新的联合国办公室。所以我们为这些人找到了一个解决方案。现在有个新的庇护项目。我们为你选择一个国家。如果你想的话，我们为你选择叙利亚、伊拉克或巴勒斯坦。
So from here, we will carry you to Syria or Iraq. So there you will die one time, very fast. Because here you die every day and very slowly. You go Syria or Iraq, you die straight away. So it becomes easy for you to die.
所以从这里，我们将把你送到叙利亚或伊拉克。所以在那儿你死一次，非常快。因为在这里你每天死，非常缓慢。去叙利亚或伊拉克，你直接死掉。所以死变得容易了。
Thank you very much.
非常感谢。
But when you take all the videos together, you realize the mission of Refugees.tv is much simpler than satire. That's not even the main focus. They just want to tell their own story instead of ceding that to someone else. And the name of the project not withstanding, in a way, they're sticking their hand in the air and saying, we're not Refugees with a capital R. We're people who were going somewhere until something stopped us.
但当你把所有视频放在一起，你意识到难民.TV的使命比讽刺简单得多。那甚至不是主要焦点。他们只是想讲自己的故事，而不是把权利让给别人。撇开项目名称不谈，某种程度上，他们把手伸向空中说，我们不是大写的“难民”。我们是本来要去某处，直到被某事停止的人。
Individually, the videos have a kind of diaristic randomness to them. And like a diary, the entries aren't always that significant. They're just what happened that day, like coming across five Europeans in a car listening to hip hop, or a little girl singing a Whitney Houston song--
单独看，这些视频有一种日记式的随机性。像日记一样，条目并不总是那么重要。它们只是那天发生的事，比如遇到五个开车听嘻哈音乐的欧洲人，或者一个小女孩唱惠特尼·休斯顿的歌——
[GIRL SINGING]
[女孩歌唱]
--or a protest or people complaining about conditions about the media, or in one case a personal drama that it seems like you'd have to be living at the camp in order to capture it. One day early last May, a guy named Abu Muhammad was beaten up while waiting in line for food. That happened a lot at Idomeni. Fights would break out in the food lines.
——或者抗议，或人们抱怨关于媒体的情况，或者在某个案例中，这看起来只有住在营地才能捕捉到的个人剧。去年五月初的一天，一个叫阿布·穆罕默德的家伙在排队领饭时被打了。在伊多梅尼这经常发生。斗殴会在饭点发生。
Because of the fight, Abu Muhammad hadn't eaten. His kids hadn't eaten. And he just snapped and decided to hang himself. He got as far as rigging up this rickety gallows by the train tracks before a whole crowd of people stopped him and tried to calm him down, at which point he just became a ball of desperation. That's where the video starts, a bunch of people surrounding a big guy in a blue coat.
因为斗殴，阿布·穆罕默德没吃到饭。他的孩子没吃到饭。他只是崩溃了，决定自杀。他在铁轨边搭建了这个歪歪扭扭的绞刑架，还没来得及死，一大群人就制止了他，并试图让他冷静下来，那时他只是变成了一个绝望的球。那是视频开始的地方，一群人包围了一个穿着蓝色外套的大个子。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
"I don't care. You will die trying to feed your children every day," he said. "I have children to feed. It's a shame on you. It's such a shame on you. You should feel ashamed of yourselves. What are you waiting for, some tea? Fear God, you people. My child is not here to be humiliated. You are driving me insane. Fear God."
“我不在乎。你们每天都会因为喂孩子而死，”他说。“我有孩子要喂。你们真可耻。你们真可耻。你们应该为自己感到羞愧。你们在等什么，茶吗？敬畏上帝，你们这些人。我的孩子不是在这里受羞辱的。你们把我逼疯了。敬畏上帝。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
As he says all this, a couple of people take down the wooden beam from where he'd wedged it between two posts.
当他说这一切时，几个人取下了他楔在两根柱子间的木梁。
Less than a month after that happened, the government finally came to clear out this whole ramshackle, unofficial camp at Idomeni. Now the guys are living at an official camp run by the military. And Basel says he was warned, in no uncertain terms by a security official who said, "No more running around as journalists documenting camp life."
事情发生不到一个月，政府终于来清除了伊多梅尼整个简陋的非官方营地。现在这些家伙住在军队运行的官方营地。巴塞尔说他得到了明确警告，一名安全官员说：“不再以记者身份记录营地生活四处跑了。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
Wow. You are in a European state now. You have to follow the European rule. Otherwise, Turkey is over there.
哇。你现在是在欧洲国家。你必须遵守欧洲规则。否则，土耳其就在那边。
Of course, freedom of the press is part of European law, but anyway.
当然，新闻自由是欧洲法律的一部分，但不管怎么说。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
This happened to me, and Mahmoud also was warned.
这发生在我身上，马哈茂德也受到警告。
And so was Mustafa. So like lots of information outlets all over the world, in light of changing market forces, they altered their format.
所以像世界各地许多信息出口一样，鉴于市场力量的变化，他们改变了形式。
You know, America's Got Talent ?
你知道《美国达人》吗？
He's saying, you know America's Got Talent ?
他说，你知道《美国达人》吗？
We're going to make Refugees Got Talent.
我们要搞“难民达人”。
Refugees Got Talent. .
《难民达人》。
Refugees Got Talent. [SPEAKING ARABIC]
《难民达人》。[阿拉伯语交谈]
The first episode went live at the beginning of June. Mahmoud, Basel, and Mustafa are the judges. It's just like America's Got Talent except they're in a tent sitting in plastic patio chairs. And there are no celebrities, no bright lights, commercials. Actually I guess it's pretty different. The audience crowds in sitting on the floor where they poke their heads into the door of the tent. Sometimes the refugee contestants really do got talent.
第一集在六月初上线。马哈茂德、巴塞尔和穆斯塔法是评委。就像《美国达人》一样，除了他们在帐篷里坐在塑料天井椅上。而且没有明星，没有耀眼的灯光，广告。其实我猜这很不一样。观众挤在地上，把头伸进帐篷门里。有时难民参赛者真的有才华。
[SINGING IN ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语歌唱]
Mahmoud is the Simon Cowell. So at the end of a performance, even if he liked it, he might throw in, "I have a piece of advice. When you sing, try to open your mouth more to give a clearer song."
马哈茂德是西蒙·考威尔。所以表演结束后，即使他喜欢它，他可能会加上一句：“我有个建议。唱歌时，试着把嘴张大一点，让歌声更清晰。”
One guy's talent is impersonating an Arab celebrity. Another does mime. He calls himself Mohammad who freezes in place. That act ends with him pretending to fall over dead.
一个家伙的才华是模仿一位阿拉伯名人。另一个表演哑剧。他称自己为“冻僵的穆罕默德”。那场表演以他假装倒地死亡告终。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's a hit. Mustafa told me the plan was to do this twice a week as the new face of Refugees.tv, a safer version that won't break the rules.
这是一场轰动。穆斯塔法告诉我计划是每周做两次，作为难民.TV的新面孔，一个不会违反规则的更安全版本。
We don't want to be in trouble with them, just trying to make some funny things.
我们不想和他们惹麻烦，只是想做点有趣的事。
But Basel told me something different, that Refugees.tv is just a way for them to get the police at the camp used to them, so that eventually they could go back to their original shenanigans. And sure enough, a month later when I looked at their Facebook page, there was a new video.
但巴塞尔告诉我的不一样，难民.TV只是让他们让营地警察习惯他们的一种方式，这样他们最终可以回到原来的恶作剧。果然，一个月后当我查看他们的Facebook页面时，有了新视频。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
It's Mustafa holding the fake mic and Basel with the fake camera interviewing a couple about their baby who was just born at the camp.
是穆斯塔法拿着假麦克风，巴塞尔拿着假相机采访一对刚在营地生下孩子的夫妇。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语交谈]
I did wonder what would happen if they got in trouble, like what the punishment would be. Mustafa said, "Maybe they arrest us, put us in a jail that's better than this one."
我确实想过如果他们惹上麻烦会怎样，惩罚会是什么。穆斯塔法说：“也许他们逮捕我们，把我们关进一个比这个更好的监狱。”
Sean Cole.
肖恩·科尔。
[MUSIC - TOM PETTY, "REFUGEE"]
[音乐 - 汤姆·佩蒂，《难民》]
Our program was produced today by Miki Meek and Joanna Kakissis. Our production staff, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, David Kestenbaum, Chana Joffe-Walt, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lyra Smith, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Our  editor is Joel Lovell. Editorial help from Julie Snyder and Elna Baker. Research help today from Michelle Harris, Benjamin Phelan, and Christopher Swetala. Our digital editor, Whitney Dangerfield. Original music today from Marcus Thorne Begala. Our fixers, Ammar Saker, Sofia Papadopoulou, Pavlos Zafiropoulos. Our interpreters, Baraa Ktiri, Manaf Abdul Ghani, and Roula Nasrallah. Additional translation, Bachar Alhalabi, Margaret Metzger, Gulie Khalaf from Yezidis International, Shafi Sharifi and Arash Afghahi.
我们的节目今天由米奇·米克和乔安娜·卡基西斯制作。我们的制作人员，佐伊·蔡斯，达娜·奇维斯，肖恩·科尔，尼尔·德拉明，伊曼纽尔·佐齐，斯蒂芬妮·傅，大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆，查娜·乔夫-沃尔特，乔纳森·门吉瓦尔，罗宾·塞米恩，阿丽莎·希普，莱拉·史密斯，马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。我们的编辑是乔尔·洛弗尔。来自朱莉·斯奈德和埃尔娜·贝克的编辑帮助。今天的研究帮助来自米歇尔·哈里斯，本杰明·费伦和克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉。我们的数字编辑，惠特尼·丹杰菲尔德。今天的原创音乐来自马库斯·索恩·贝加拉。我们的向导，阿马尔·萨克尔，索菲亚·帕帕多普洛，帕夫洛斯·扎菲罗普洛斯。我们的翻译，巴拉·克蒂里，马纳夫·阿卜杜勒·加尼和鲁拉·纳斯鲁拉。额外翻译，巴查尔·阿尔哈拉比，玛格丽特·梅茨格，雅兹迪国际的古利·哈拉夫，沙菲·沙里菲和阿拉什·阿夫加希。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website where you can go to our interactive tour of five refugee camps, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to Public Radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，你可以去我们的五个难民营互动导览，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX传递给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, we only met because he  saw me across the room at the public radio convention, walked up and said,
一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，我们只是因为他在公共广播大会上隔着房间看到我，走过来并说：
Wow, you look beautiful. Can I speak to you?
哇，你看起来真漂亮。能跟你说说话吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。